This is Jocko podcast number one 83 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good Evening Echo. Good evening.
Okay.
Not One of the guys on the ground at bike. This mission
now moving to within a click of their target,
they had pushed that distraction from their minds and were solely focused on the
deadly challenge before them glancing at the gps attached to the stock of his
rifle and scanning the terrain ahead.
Lieutenant Commander James Reese called a quick perimeter.
Snipers were already moving up to the high ground as team leaders joined Reese
for a last quick update before the final push to the objective.
Okay.
Even with all the technology at their disposal,
things could go wrong in a heartbeat.
Their enemy was cunning and highly adaptive after 16 years at war,
the Afghan saying the Americans all have the watches,
but we have all the time.
Okay.
Rang a bit more true than it had in the early days.
What do you think Reese asked?
A huge beast of a man looking like a creature from another world with his a o R,
one patterned camouflaged body armor and ops core half shell helmet with nods
firmly in place.
Reese looked at his most seasoned troop chief,
the light green glow of the nods illuminated through the beard on the man's
face,
a slight smile that could not be mistaken for anything other than the confident
look of a professional special operations soldier.
It's just over the rise. Reese replied, Predator shows nothing moving.
No centuries, nothing. His troop chief nodded.
All right guys. He said to the other four men in the circle, let's do it.
They rose with resolve and moved with the poise of men who are comfortable in
chaos.
Moving up the rocky ridge line to get their teams in place before approaching
the target to make entry.
Okay,
this is too easy. You're thinking too much. Again, it's just another mission.
Then why this feeling? Maybe it's just the headaches.
The headaches had played Reese for the past several months.
Finally prompting a visit to
Balboa Naval Medical Center before this deployment for a series of tests.
Still no word back from the docs. Maybe it's nothing.
Okay,
but maybe it's something.
Okay.
We had learned a long time ago that if something didn't look right,
then it probably wasn't
that judgement had kept him and his men alive on many of deployment.
Everything had lined up a little too easy for this target, the Intel,
the offset in fill the current state of the objective area
and why the pressure from higher authority to go after this target.
When was the last time a flag level command injected itself into a tactical
planning process? Something wasn't adding up.
Maybe everything's fine. Maybe it's the headaches.
Maybe it's a bit of paranoia.
Okay,
maybe I'm getting too old for this focus. Reese,
this wasn't the first time that they had approached our target.
They had suspected was a possible ambush at one point in the war when Intel,
it pointed to the high possibility of an ambush corroborated by multiple
sources. Both human and technical.
Reese would have knocked on the door with a thermobaric 84 or a few one oh five
rounds from an AC [inaudible] gunship.
This was the first time that actual tactics had been dictated from higher for
men who would not be on the ground.
Focus on the mission. Reese.
One more check with the tactical operation center.
A forward based command also called the talk and to look at the Predator feed.
Nothing.
Another check with the sniper teams. Nothing moving.
We use glanced up at the military crest of the hill in front of him.
Through his nods, he could see the assault teams set and ready to move.
He couldn't see the snipers,
which gave him cause for a thoughtful smile.
Best in the business.
Reese keyed his radio and opus opened his mouth to give the order to move.
Then it all went black.
Okay?
The explosion knocked Reese back 10 yards and ripped his helmet from his head as
the entire military crest of the hill in front of him.
You re-upped it in a concussion of violence and death.
Teammates, friends,
husbands and fathers who one moment earlier had represented the best spas,
special operations force in the world.
We're gone in less than a second,
okay?
Okay.
Somewhere.
A true believer is training to kill you.
He is training with minimum food or water in austere conditions day and night.
The only thing cleaned on him is his weapon
and he made his web gear.
He doesn't worry about what workout to do. His rockways,
what it weighs.
His runs end when the enemy stops chasing him.
The true believer doesn't care how hard it is.
He only knows that he wins
or he dies.
[inaudible]
he doesn't go home at 1700
he is home.
He only knows the cause
and
those right there or two excerpts from two books.
The first one, a book called the Terminal List and the second book,
a book called true believer and these books are
[inaudible]
fiction.
They are novels and with the exception of the novel Musashi by Eli Yoshikawa.
I have not covered any novels on the podcast,
but I'm actually not here to talk about those novels.
The novels of these books were written by a seal,
a seal that I knew,
and a seal that is here with us tonight to share his experiences in the teams,
what he learned, how he ended up,
where he did as a retired seal officer,
a husband, a father,
and a writer of fiction.
His name is Jack Carr. Welcome to the show.
Thank you so much for having me on. It's great to be here. Yeah, man. Good,
good to finally get you out here.
I know we tried to hook this up for a little while. Yep. It's a, it's good. And,
and, and you sent me your latest book and I'd said to myself, okay,
well let's just make this happen. Awesome. So, yeah, man,
let's talk a little bit about you. Well, that, that's hard,
but I've never heard that a true believer read quite so well.
So I used to read that to my guys in the teams and then read your, uh,
laws of combat. Read those to them, Kinda to [inaudible] that one, you know,
just kind of set the stage about what the Syria, who we're going after here. Uh,
and then your laws of combat, which of course I, um, yeah, pass on.
Everybody I ever worked with ever since. Right on,
you probably found a couple of them in the book for those that, that read them.
There's a couple, I put them in Italics, you know, give you credit jack.
Uh, so let's, let's talk a little bit about, you know, where it all started.
Yeah. Like your, what year were you born? Yeah, 73. Okay.
So you're kind of a young and well off. What are you, one year old? 71. Okay.
Yeah. Yeah. Dominant child of the 80s, though.
You know that those former of the years were like 80 to 89 or you grew up in
north county. Norco. And my mom was librarian and from a very early age,
this is one area or city area. A rural. Yeah, but not too rural.
Small town, I'd say small town. Yeah. So north of San Francisco. Um,
but uh, wealth today is d day. Um,
so probably appropriately talk about that.
My grandfather was killed in World War II. Some were very early age. Uh,
I was surrounded by those silk mappings and aviator marine, uh,
flew the course air, which was that plane that had the,
the wings that would fold up. Um,
right about that time there was a show black sheep squadron on TV.
I went to an air show and met pappy Boyington before he passed away.
I got his book signed. And, um, so I always knew that, uh,
the military was where I was going. Um, just earlier on,
I didn't know exactly what that was going to be, but, uh,
cause you ever thinking about trying to be a pilot, you know, fleetingly,
I'm sure I did, but we're all marine corps, uh,
fleetingly as a pilot just following the footsteps of my grandfather. Um, but,
and it became very obvious that, uh,
that my skill set laid a more primal level on the ground.
It was just attracted to that for some reason. Um, probably a lot of, you know,
in the DNA for sure,
but also the influence of popular culture that books and movies that I read
growing up. Um, those are the guys that I, that I wanted to be like. And,
and had backgrounds that I, I wanted to have one day, but, um,
my grandfather didn't make it back from, from World War II,
so he was killed off Okinawa in 1945 in May, so near the end of the war.
And, uh, but his, his wings made it back old pictures of his, uh,
black and white pictures of his squadron. And by his plane,
the silk maps they give a few years back then,
cause if they hit the water with paper, they'd just disintegrate.
So I had these silk maps. Um, so I just grew up with him really as kind of the,
the ideal hero I guess. Um,
obviously never met him and neither did my dad cause he was a born while he was
deployed. So, uh, so grew up with just knowing that the military was my calling.
There was never anything else I wanted to do.
And then early on I found out what seals were. And your mom was a librarian?
Yup. Yup. Still is to this day. And so were you into reading? Yup. Yeah.
I grew up surrounded by books and uh, yeah,
just always naturally gravitated when I got to be about fifth grade,
I'd say towards the things that, uh, the adults were reading at the time.
So Tom Clancy, David Morrell, Nelson to mill AAJ, Cornell, JC Pollack, uh,
mark olden, these guys in the 80s,
that ad protagonists with seal backgrounds or CIA backgrounds or a special
forces background. So, um,
not having the Internet and not having that many nonfiction books written about
seals. Uh,
that's what I read and I knew this is where I'm going and then after that's
done, I want to write fiction like these guys.
So those are the two things that I wanted to do with my life.
How old were you when you actually found out about the seal teams in fifth
grade? A seven. So [inaudible] second grade, second grade,
you found out about the two themes from what?
So that then there were four channels back then growing up.
So there was like ABC, CBS, NBC,
and then that one outlier channel that always had some world war two movie on it
going all the time. And, uh, I was at remote control back in the late seventies,
so, uh, Sundays were football days and I was not interested in football at all.
Uh, but I was interested in that warm movie with playing opposite football.
So at a commercial,
my dad would look at his watch and I can still remember to this day sitting on
the couch and he'd say, go. And then I'd have two minutes to run up,
change that channel to that outlier channel and then sit back down,
watch that movie. And then he'd say, turn it back,
back to football two minutes later. So I got to do that and,
and I just wait through the football parts and then run up and change it to
whatever war movie was playing.
So this cross is attention deficit disorder without question. Yeah.
To be trained for incredible patients and imagination.
You've got to fill in the blanks direct that during that. That might be,
it might be. It, it, uh, yeah. So one of those movies was the frogmen. And, uh,
it showed these guys climbing up over the beaches ahead of the conventional
force landing and putting explosives on these, uh, obstacles.
And I asked my dad, hey, who are these guys? And uh, he said those are frogmen.
And I said, okay, what's a frogman? He said, ask your mother. So, uh, so I did.
And then we went down to the local library cause she would take any,
any excuse to get us to the library and do research,
show us how to use the Dewey decimal system, pull out the card things,
the whole deal and uh,
did a little research and there was hardly anything written back then.
There was a couple of magazines that had mentions of seals, um,
a couple nonfiction books that had a chapter or a paragraph or two on ceilings.
Not much at all. And, uh,
but my takeaway was that these guys are touted anyway as one of the most elite
fighting forces in the world.
And the training is the toughest ever devised by our modern military, arguably.
And that was my takeaway. We all know that's arguable. They, exactly,
there's all kinds of different hard parts of all different training. You know,
I,
I'd never went to ranger school and if I did go Eton MRE one MRU Day, I ruin,
not be a happy camper. Brutal. But, you know, so everyone's got their little,
their level challenges or heard the same thing. Exactly. So they had me and,
yeah. And you find out that it's, so what did you do?
Did you start preparing for it physically? Yep. Oh yeah. Everything we're doing,
everything I did from that. So I guess I do it an early form of crossfit,
I guess, uh, before, uh, before crossfit was a thing in high school.
So not in the, you know, in the younger years, junior high,
I was still playing soccer right around cross country doing all that sorts.
But I do credit cross country, uh,
in those hills in northern California with giving me for whatever reason that
no, never quit. Uh,
I'd see people stopping on the hill that was giving you energy,
like a pretty good runner. I was. Okay. Yeah, it was good.
But there were some guys that were really, really good. Um, mine was just,
you know, Doug and determination really. Um,
so I was pretty good but not the greatest. Um, and, you know,
but I'd love it when I'd see people walking,
especially on the hills when people from the flatlands would come up to our
horse and, uh, and they picked that first hill and just walk.
It would just devastate them and that, which is,
I just feed off that kind of like a whole week when people would quit.
And I always feel bad talking about this, but I mean, it's true.
Some people would say, come back, no, don't quit. Come back.
I didn't say one word. This is exactly,
this is what this program is designed to do. Uh, and so I kind of fed off that.
I guess. I love it, especially when the biggest, strongest,
fastest guys for those first three weeks or whatever it was, a buds, uh, with,
with the verse couple, that's all just duds,
just quitting first couple of hours.
I don't know if people said that was gonna happen and uh, and it did.
And I'm studs where I thought to myself, wow,
this guy seems like a complete stud. Yup. Mentally,
physically, you know, just legit and then just quit app right away.
How is that? I don't know,
but I would look at these guys when I first showed up the buds, I'm like, man,
that guy's huge and he's doing great climbing these ropes and he's like losing
his legs and like, oh my God,
it's going to go on those monkey bar things and Geez,
how am I going to make it through if this guy, this guy,
like they just got like that here and then he quits and I'm like, oh,
I see how this works. You're mentally weak. Exactly. I can do this.
Yup. So, so you did running? Yeah, we did cross country. Yup.
Early on did that stuff. Soccer, um, a Lacrosse in, uh, in high school,
but then I'd ride my bike to school, which was, I don't know how long,
not at least 10 miles, I guess. So early morning, northern California cold. Um,
and cause I was, it was part of training and I'd get home and we had this, um,
kind of place that whatever from when we were kids and, and I do, you know,
pull up solely to holding different, you know,
trying to try to make an obstacle course for myself when I got home and I would
be knocking out like 20 pull ups at whatever, 13,
14 years old and then go have like some pasta or a piece of bread with butter on
it for my snack. Um, and uh, and started training, not charter,
train martial arts pretty early too. Um, but I didn't, I was searching cause uh,
uh, local taekwondo place. Right. And here's the joint,
some cotta stuff and you're learning a little bit and you've even, you're,
how old were you? Uh, that would probably be freshmen. 14,
let's say even as a 14 year old, you're like, wow,
like this seems like many work, but it also seems like,
what if someone hits me in the face? Yeah. Work Greg, a 13 year old.
Yep. Kind of picked up on that. Yep.
Which is I give you credit because I'm guys can be convincing, you know,
that's how you see these videos of people online that are making people fall
down by cleaning out the middle. There is yelling their key. I Adam,
I know it's hilarious. People literally fall down him and start shaking.
It's crazy. Yeah. It's crazy.
But I can say I grew up also like to talk about that, uh,
the influence of popular culture. So, uh, you know, rocky movies, I was just,
wow, man, that's fighting right there. I want to learn how to do that.
How do I learn how to do that in northern California where there wasn't really a
place to go, but, uh, that, that tenacity, you know,
like getting up every time you get knocked down.
Like I think those things have really wore off on me.
Like I took that seriously. Um, and still do to this day.
What kind of music were you listening to? I didn't really do the music thing.
Tell
a little the last few years really. I was like quiet. Yup. Yup.
I realized I'm starting to give music less credit than I used to for,
I used to look, I used to,
when I meet people and I talk to them for a little bit, I'd go out,
what kind of music did you listen to growing up?
Because we would always kind of fill me in about kind of who they were.
Because when, when we grew up, you,
you only listened to what you kind of, you,
you didn't get exposed to a bunch of stuff.
You kind of had to figure it out and go down that channel.
And so if you listened to heavy metal, okay, I see, you know,
I see what you were doing or you listened to, you know, Leonard Skinner don't,
okay, cool. I get where I get. You could just kind of know,
cause people wouldn't say, because what does everyone say now?
What are you listen to?
They say everything because everything's free and they can listen to all this
different kinds and it's wide open. And that's what all these kids say nowadays.
I listened to everything, a little bit of everything.
And so don't offend anyone. Yeah. Yeah. And so you just weren't even in music?
Nope, not until I got my driver's license and then I kinda had to,
cause you had other people in the car and they'd bring a cassette tape.
I'm like a mix tape and a and put that thing in. And uh,
for whatever reason where I grew up, people listened to uh, stuff like sixties,
seventies, [inaudible] my dad had a, uh,
a Barracuda and the the car, like the sports car,
like the sense of three Barracuda, yellow with [inaudible].
And you're saying it impressed, but it was not because it was,
it was my dad being a broke teacher,
needed a new car and went out and paid whatever,
1800 bucks for this car that was rusty, but it had an eight track in it.
I'm sorry. And my dad, I think he had one eight track and it was Hank Williams,
like Hank Williams was it? Yeah, Hank Williams Sr.
So we listen to a lot of Hank Williams. When I was growing up,
we had Kenny Rogers, we had the Gambler, I'm sorry to hear that.
We are the gamble every morning and dropped off for school.
It wasn't an eight track. I think my dad was an early adopter. [inaudible]
exactly. And I remember to this day, every day on the way to school.
Was it the gambler? All right. So what did your dad do? Uh,
it was an attorney at that time and I got into real estate and then later on and
then retired early. And so, okay, so you're, you're now,
at what point did you say, okay, I'm going to, I'm going to go for sure.
Like what point was this? 10 years old. Was this 12 years old? Seven,
seven years old. Our idea, this is what I'm doing, I'm going.
And what made you decide any, anything else significant from high school? Your,
you're playing soccer, you're playing lacrosse. Yeah, running,
you're doing pull ups on the monkey bars, whatever, trail run,
all that sort of thing. Just getting ready,
thinking about my next steps and knowing that there was going to be a little bit
of pause there to go to college first just in case because we have to have
contingency plans. Tertiary. So second you looked and said like, okay,
I'm going to go to college. Yup, Yup. That person,
I need to do that cause I needed to get a stronger, bigger, faster. Um,
and uh, I thought I needed to anyway. I don't know if that's the case or not,
but probably not. But you were just more humble and you were thinking, Hey,
I need to be in better shape than I thought there was eight guys on a seal team
and, uh, I was going to be one of those guys and if I
was going to be one of those guys, I needed to be in the best possible shape.
And at that time the best possible shape looked like Stallone and looked like
Arnold. So I did not look like either of those guys. So,
and I still don't, and I never did, but, but I thought,
and I need to hit the iron here. I need to get boxing.
And I did a little bit in high school. So, uh, so that, go back to that, uh,
martial arts school or taekwondo thing, there was an instructor there that, uh,
kind of knew that this wasn't quite the deal, like a brown belt in taekwondo.
And then for my last, I guess, year and a half of high school, uh,
he wanted to start his own thing. And so he'd,
I'd go pick him up in my car cause you didn't have one and we'd go to a local
park and we box and it was like jab, reverse hook, you know,
you know the basics and uh, and that was awesome.
I'd love to re I absolutely loved it up the largest 24. Yes, exactly. Um,
my learned about a take down was, you know, like, cause he did some wrestling.
Oh. So I got to do a little of that early MMA. Exactly, exactly.
Yup. If you had a car you couldn't really make something happen. It's such a,
Greg and he's, and he's still doing it today. Yeah. Mike Valentine, his name.
I've seen him in years, but he has a, a,
a place up in northern California and he's still still doing it.
And as soon as he found out about Jujitsu, he was doing that for,
he was driving to San Francisco and working out with whoever was the San
Francisco guy in the early nineties, I guess. And uh, yeah,
we're talking about health greasy. I don't know Charles Gracie vape.
There's a bunch of options up there, but nobody was really doing that.
Nobody was mixing stuff up like that, that I knew about anyway,
and where my in my little town of whatever, you know,
however many people it was. Um, but then I just kept on that path,
just kept doing it. I thought it was gonna be a lifelong path and uh,
but I peaked in about 95 and that was in college. Yeah.
So you end up going to college. What do you, what'd you go to study college for?
Uh, well, I want it, well, I wanted to get out of there as soon as possible,
so I get to the seal teams. And so justice studies seemed to be,
the criminology seem to be there. The thing that you could just, hey,
that's kind of interesting and uh,
I can get through this thing in four years and get to the teams and your backup
plan would have been good. Some credit cop or something like that I guess.
But I didn't really waste too much time thinking about a backup plan.
I just knew that college having that degree was the backup plan.
But I figured that out later it was full on devoted to figuring out how to get
to the teams and they'd be in the best shape I could mentally, physically,
spiritually before I got there. When did you go to a recruiter?
What Year of college? Uh, after I finished. Oh,
so after you finished and I thought it was going to be like Forrest Gump.
Like you,
you go to the recruiter and there's a bus waiting outside and you walk through
and you get on a bus and off you go. Like I didn't know. Totally ignorant. Yeah,
it's crazy. Until you do it, you know? I mean,
I did research enough to find out that there was something called a die fairer
program. And My, uh, my recruiter didn't even know what it was,
but I was in the back of a book and I forget the name of the book,
a paperback book that talked about all sorts of different special operations and
like,
and it had like one paragraph on how to get to those places and put the steel,
it said Diet Fair program. So I went in there, it was kind of a scam.
I did the, I did that program two total scan.
It's like they get you to sign on for six years
and a, they say you get, you guaranteed a chance to see it to try out.
That's all I know. I want the guarantee to try out. That's all I need. And uh,
then you get to boot camp and everybody got a chance in when I was there any way
to try out. I sign up for six these guys for four and we all get the chance.
Dang it. Uh, but anyway, ended up spending the, uh, the 20 years in any way.
Yeah. So you, you, what year was it that you actually enlisted in the navy?
96 96. So got it. I called and I thought, like I said,
I thought I was gonna walk on that bus and then I'm training and I roll my ankle
and I'm like, Oh man, this is gonna be the end.
And I can't believe it's like this huge, I thought it was broken. Uh,
I ended up just being, you know, whatever that's spraying nothing. I lost
21 and uh, get the tow. You think he's seeing this black and blue ankle?
That's huge. And uh, it's like, Oh man, what did I do? Austin run. And I do.
Why was I trained in that day? I should just take, I should've just relaxed,
not gotten hurt. And then soaps on crutches for a couple of months and uh,
and got back after it and got in the pool.
How long was it from the time you enlisted until the time you shipped out?
Uh, Gosh, you know,
there's all those things you're supposed to do ahead of time. When you're on a,
what do they call them? You're supposed to be going to classes there.
I didn't do any of that maths I think. Yeah,
I didn't do any of that stuff though cause it was encouraged.
But I somewhere I found out it was not mandatory and I was like,
okay good cause I don't want to have to, you know,
do whatever these 10 pushups or these people, I knew they actually training a,
was it a month ago? No, it was uh, it was months. Yeah, it wasn't years. No,
it was like five months or five months or something. Yeah.
That's just a like a little heads up to people like you think what?
Like what you thought, which is what I thought, hey,
once I sign up I'm just going to get on a bus and that's cool. I'm good. Yeah.
And really you got to go survive for another five months or six months as you're
waiting to go. Cause they have certain billets allowed and all this stuff.
So it's kind of a pain. Yep. And you got to do the medical stuff,
the dental stuff, take the as Bab and all that sort of thing to get ready.
So those a couple of trips over to the main recruiting station to do all those
sorts of things. Get over, they'll paperwork in line and then uh,
then off you go. So, and then I was in, now they have every,
all the people that are going to be in some sort of naval special warfare or
something more squared away now I think. So they go through like they go to,
they go to Chicago I think for eight weeks. So get ready for bugs. Yep.
So you showed up to bugs. Were you ready for boats? Uh,
as I always as ready as one could possibly be with all that training and all
that thought, and then I knew, hey,
there's no way I'm quitting because all my friends growing up knew that I wanted
to do this since I was seven and a so there's no way I'm quitting my die.
I can't go home and tell them I didn't make it.
You know what's weird as people do that right there and they still quit. Yeah.
Which boggles my mind.
I though the quitting thing is hard for me to comprehend.
And when I hear about people doing it, look, people like that, you know,
there was a guy that killed himself recently and he was that guy and,
and he had told everyone, I'm going to be a seal.
And he had trained for it and he prepared for it. And he looked like a stud.
He looked like a beast of a kid and he played lacrosse and he was varsity this
and captain of that. I mean,
and then he got to buds and for whatever reason he quit and then he,
and then he killed himself. And you just think, man,
like whatever they're telling you in buds, you don't quit.
Don't quit. It's pretty easy. Yeah, just do not quit.
And I know they play psychological games on people of saying,
you know, they'll say you don't belong here, and all this kind of stuff.
I don't even remember if they said that to me.
I didn't care what they said to me.
It wasn't even penetrating anything in my brain. Uh, but, but you know,
that's what they do. They, they'll say, oh, you don't belong here.
We don't want you on the team.
And somebody that's sensitive to that it can get through to them shit and make
them start believing that the instructors, actually,
the instructors are going to leave and go order a pizza. They don't,
they're not actually thinking about that, you know,
but they take some kid and they quit. And you know what good, like you said,
like good that if someone has that, if someone is going to quit,
please quit during buds for sure.
Did you guys watch a full metal jacket?
I mean there's all these movies that they show drill instructors and what it's
like to yell at you. People are screaming at you, it's going to be a game.
Did you have any trouble with anything of boats?
So I swam before I got there and I'd wake up super early week,
the master swim program at five in the morning. Um,
cause I knew swimming was my weak point. I mean I swam,
I had no problem with swimming, but I wasn't, uh, a competitive swimmer.
You are so much more prepared for bugs than me. I'm just like,
even the fact that you analyze like what your strengths and weaknesses were.
I was just, I was just like, that's another way to go. Yeah.
It worked out but I was young too, which is beneficial. You know,
it's beneficial just to be young cause you're just going to adapt.
I mean your brain isn't even completely developed until you're what,
24 1819 years old. I was just full,
full adaptation to whatever they're telling me.
That's what you have to do in life in general. But uh,
but I remember I distinctly remember going to the pool.
So I'm rehabbing my ankle at this point. Um,
and I'm going to the pool now and it's flipped.
It's outdoors and it just like,
not snow but that frost layer of frost on the pool deck. So once you got in,
it was actually kind of warm,
but you still have to walk across that pool deck and jump in with these people
that are way older but way faster.
I was definitely the slowest person in this masters swim program cause these
people had, you know, swung competitive leaving.
Now they're 45 and which was old time,
42 years old person sitting in your life and they're swimming at five in the
morning. Dang. Um, but uh, so I did that. So I was prepared, uh,
for the water and I grew up in the water essentially grouping that scuba diving
at age nine until I was comfortable in the water. Once again,
you are so much more prepared. I was like, you know, well I mean I I knew I was,
I could swim and I served as a kid and that helped but I definitely wasn't scuba
diving. Yeah. I lost that three diving for abalone up north. Um,
so I spent with all those [inaudible]. I don't know if I do that now.
It's like a great white good breeding ground up for sure. But abalone
was amazing. I loved that we camp out up there and just have a great time. But,
but even though I prepared like that the swims were hard and that first swim,
cause it's that underwater recovery stroke in 1996 they didn't teach you.
Now they teach you how to do this thing. Yeah. Now get in the water,
here's your little basics, here's how you do it. Bring your head up, whatever.
Um, so I had like, what stroke is this? None of the books talked about this.
Let me try to do it. We can get this master's program,
what's not in the master swim program. Um, and I was third to last.
I remember getting out of that first one where they pair everybody up and
whatever they call it, the two weeks before you class up,
whatever that thing is called. Um, and I was like, man, I'm third to land.
I can stagger it out of the water. Like I put out on this thing. And I'm like,
wow, what's, anyway, they pair me up with this really slow guy. Um,
and I think he quit right away.
So then they paired me up with somebody else who was faster. Um,
so I'm barely making the swims in first phase.
And then one of the guys in my class was a water polo player, uh,
from like USC or something like that. And he's like, Hey,
you want me to teach you how to do this stroke? I'm like, yeah, it'd be great.
And so we went out behind the barracks thing and went out in the ocean and he
just showed me how to do it.
And then I went from being third to last to the next swim. I was third.
There you go. That was awesome. And I was never third again.
I was like fifth or sixth, whatever. But from going from third to last,
I distinctly remember to then coming out third after learning the stroke,
I was like, I got this. It's different to swimming with fins too.
And the way that they teach you to do it is a little bit different, whatever.
But now they prepare. Now you're prepared going in physically like that. Uh,
that eight weeks they spend in, in uh, Chicago, they learned the strokes,
they learned how to lift the logs and not hurt themselves and how to, uh,
you know, I use the boat, there's instructions on how to lift the log seizure.
Oh Wow. How to climb the ropes, mental toughness classes, all that stuff.
But you know, what happened? Of course,
once those guys showed up and they were all expecting a lot more seals to come
through now because they needed more in 2003 five, four, five, six,
we need more seals. So let's do this program.
And now we just got the fitter quitters and a so same essentially the crazy
thing, the crazy thing is the attrition rate doesn't change. Exactly. Fitter.
Quitters are quitters. I liked that because it's,
it doesn't matter how many pull ups you can do. I mean it does matter.
And people say to me, was it mental or physical?
It's definitely both of you can't do, if you can't climb a rope,
you're not making it through it. It doesn't matter how bad you,
if you haven't put in the work, you're not gonna be able to climb a rope. Yeah,
you can get some fitter quitters. Exactly. I always did.
Any average high school athlete physically can do and make it through,
but it's obviously the metal parts there that comes in and you get guys that are
in amazing shape, guys that were Olympic athletes or whatever it is,
and they quit right away. And I think a lot of that,
and like the guy that killed himself maybe, maybe hadn't, you know,
faced adversity in the, uh, in the the ways that you need to,
to figure out how to actually overcome it and how to get knocked down and,
you know, moving forward. Um, and you know, you're going to get hurt,
you're going to play hurt. And a lot of these guys aren't used to that.
They're used to be being treated in a way where if they're hurt,
they have someone's right there.
They're there making sure that they're okay and they're going to rehab and all
that stuff. It's not, you know, they're like
Lamborghinis, they're going to the shop a lot.
There's no one that really crushes buds. No, I don't think so. Just like,
Oh yeah, everything was easy cause there'll be some really good athletes.
And I did have some stud athletes and Mike, my honor man,
was a guy named Keith [inaudible] who was just a boy.
He just fast at everything and strong. He was just a beast, you know?
And so I would say there, I guess there are a few guys that crush bugs,
but most people, they're going to have some, they're going to like,
they're going to pick apart some weak points in you. Yep.
And that's what you want. I want it to be tested. That was the whole,
that was one of the main draws. I was like,
how did you make it through first time every time. No, so I had a,
after hell week my legs weren't working, whatever stress or whatever,
whatever it was. So they yanked me off the next swim because I was just no,
no sinking probably and said, you're going to medical and cushion. Like, no,
I'm not going to medical [inaudible] take me alive.
Exactly. I mean, I remember them pulling me out onto the boat and be like,
you are going to medical now. And I was like, Dang it. So I went in there and,
but it worked for me whenever they did.
Like some people stayed there at that time.
Like you'd have a guy in there for like a year just kind of hiding out. Um,
but for me it worked,
it just legs near a little rest and then classed up with the next class and next
class. What was your attitude when you got rolled?
Was it like the end of your life where you like, oh my God. Or were you like,
okay cool, I'm going to, cause I guess there's so many people get rolled back.
Yeah, yeah. I was a little bummed cause I had friends with all these guys,
they're going on to die phase and you're like, oh,
you're watching them go on dive phase. And you're like,
but then a lot of them get rolled back for pool comp and then you've got half
your class back again. So that was great.
I had a pool comp was my favorite like that.
And a drown proofing because that's the only time you get to forget physical and
instructor. And the other time, like you're just there, you're getting,
you're getting yelled at, you're being told you're worthless, you know,
whatever. But this is the time where it's motto, we motto,
it's like you against them and uh, you know, you, it's a little bit physical.
So I love pool comp pass. First Time I was comfortable in the water. Um,
but then the drown proofing also that's what you really get in physical when
they have those different types of bodies that you have to save.
You mean lifesaving like saying yeah, for sure. Lifesaving.
So they have the guides,
they're dead weight and then they one that's fighting you and that's the one I
liked. That was awesome. And they drag you to the bottom and I just be like,
and there's probably the martial arts stuff just relax cause he's working,
he's working to keep me down there at the bottom and then when he comes up for
air then I just go a little little more than that.
He get his air and he dragged me back down. But it was like us together.
Like I loved that part. That was my favorite part of buttons.
What I figured out, I figured out what the show called, right?
I figured out like, okay, this is a choke,
like a rear naked choke that I can use and the recovery is you, you,
I think you put your arm over like almost the same way you grab them like by the
lat on the other side. And I just realized, Oh, if I just pay it over here,
it's going to choke this dude and it's gonna make them like get under control
and then boom, I can go back to the position. But yeah,
I had a good time with that. I failed pool comp. Oh yeah.
Because the former UDT guy from nom who ended up working for at trade at
[inaudible] and one day I asked him, I said, you know,
do you remember family in Pool comp? He goes, Oh yeah,
I was just messing with you. I was like, oh cool. Thanks. Yeah, that's awesome.
I appreciate it. And then I passed the next time. But yeah, those, those,
the water I was pretty comfortable, comfortable in from surfing growing up,
but nice for me. Everything I had to work hard. I didn't run hard,
all that stuff. That's all things. That's what it's all about. So you get done,
you get done with buds and where'd you end up going? Go on team five. And uh,
you know, back then you're like, oh, it's gonna happen. No,
North Korea is going to happen. I said,
I've got to give here weeding stuff in the air.
It's still going to happen if you read the news. Uh, so, uh,
I went to teen five, that was my first choice. Um, and just because of that.
So now it's 1997, 1997. Yep.
Showing up. Right Eric? Yeah. So I was still on the west coast at this time.
I was over at team one. Yep. And I was, I was in training,
so probably got those right around when I got picked up for a commissioning
program. So I'm just trying to think timeframe,
like all the guys that I know from team five were all there. Yeah.
Well old school nineties welcoming you aboard. Oh yeah. Very great.
Very gentle loving environment. Yeah. You know, actually I loved it, you know,
and I thought we'd get there of course and get issued a pager and then they'd
give us all this awesome gear and we'd be at the bar drinking and all of a
sudden they go off like in the movies and we'd fly off and you know,
save the princess and get back in time for a beers the next night.
And then I get there and it's like, Hey, new guy,
clean that toilet and paint that wall and change those light bulbs.
And I was like, Roger, that, let's do it. I'm gonna Change.
I'm gonna be the best light bulb changer that, uh, that you've got here. And uh,
so that was a little different. A little,
did you go through SQT at group one or did you go through it second time? Yeah,
it was the second class at group one. And uh, yeah,
so I went through that one and you know, it was good.
There was professionalizing standardizing things.
Obviously it's more professional now, but uh, yeah, it was great time.
I loved that. I had a blast. All of the, you rolled into what's, what was your,
what was your position in your first platoon? What'd you do?
I see a assistant comm guy. So, uh, for whatever reason, they're like,
oh, college, you're going to comp school. Oh Dang it.
I want to reach the point man. Exactly.
You must be smart enough to say you must've wanted to be appointment. Yeah,
of course. You read those books, right. Point man. Of course the foot patches,
Watson, that's what you want to do. Watching all those movies.
So when they told me I was gonna be a calm guy, I was like, Dang it, you know,
that's the guy that will want it. The guy to get shot, first of all,
the Vietnam and he's right next to the LTA agent located, we make,
and he's got the tennis sticking up in the jungle and the over the grass.
And that's where they, so anyway,
but I did that and it was actually a great experience being a calm guy because
you're part of the planning processes that your guy, um,
and then you're learning the radios. Yeah, it was great. So, um,
going through that comscores and then bringing back the, the newest,
whenever you waste radios, newest techniques, whatever it is to the platoon.
So even though you have a primary calm guy, um, you kind of know,
you know what's going on after that. That's a good course. There was anyway,
it was long course. Um, so it was good to be part of the planning process.
So as for someone that was gonna be an officer at some point,
I got to experience, did you, and you even have that in your brain?
I knew it was an option. Yeah, it was an option.
So it was either that or the other east coast seal team. And uh, you know,
I wanted to do both of those things. I thought, uh, but I figured, Hey,
let's give this a shot. Let's give this a little, it's checking out.
I'm brand new, figure this out and see if, uh,
I'm going to be an officer one day or go to another seal team or move on and go
to the, you know, Central Intelligence Agency.
Like all the people I'd read about and, and watched in the movies. Um, so,
and there's nothing going on, right. There's nothing going on.
Exactly. And nothing happening, you know,
some shit boardings like one platoon digital,
a ship boarding wasn't your platoon? No, no. As long as that was, I did,
I did some ship boardings Burke and the dairy,
well I did them retro September 11 it was, this was before that.
So it was like wow, pre September 11th doing shipboard. Yeah. I was like,
you know, I was walking around like I was damn he had, you know,
the like whoever was walking around like I was like,
Oh God, bad experiences. Like no you're a loser.
But back then that's what you wanted to be doing.
No and to be quite frank and we weren't walking around like,
but we were completely stoked that we got to do something real that I got to
lock and load my gun like that. That was cool. And it was good. It was,
you know, good enough. Cause most guys didn't get to do that.
Most time you don't.
Many guys would just go on deployment and they would train other, other,
you know, foreign militaries on how to do stuff. That's cool.
Build relationships with other countries. Cool. All that. Do some big exercises.
Cool. But to actually lock in, load your weapon and get,
have a real loadout was pretty,
was like a big step back down.
And it felt great for me. But this was,
so this is 97 and where'd you go on deployment? Uh, so that was a pay comm.
So it was a shipboard or no, no, not, no, no.
This was all the things you just talked about. [inaudible] in South Korea,
countries, trout Australia or wherever else.
So just done the normal pay calm type thing.
Well Pre September 11th with not much going on.
And then you come back from that deployment and roll right into another platoon.
Cause that's what the guys do. They become one cruise. Wonder,
you get promoted to one cruise wonder, Oh yeah,
we're either primary comms guy or did you skate out of calm? So I know.
How did you get any good schools in between? Yep. What'd you get? False sniper.
Oh Wow. Yeah. So we'll trouble, yeah. So snipers, what I want,
you must've been squared away cause they don't just give those schools away.
I mean, I don't know. You asked my chief. Yeah, I did. I checked with him.
He was a crazy man, that guy, but a, yeah. So right. Ticked by to sniper school,
which is what I wanted, which I always wanted to do. So, uh, so got there.
Did a with 73 days I guess.
And what color lingo are you get the valley fever going on. So,
uh, in past, so I passed,
but I didn't pass docking cause I didn't grow up doing that sort of thing.
So I was shooting, you know, that was good. I grew up shooting. Um, so had,
I had no problems there. Uh, but then the stocking was a, was a shock to me.
I didn't really understand what was going on was crawling people.
I was crawling for a thousand meters, you know,
out to do this and you can just walk for most of that. You know,
I didn't know that at the time. You know,
those of us that didn't know what were doing were just crawling
in island in the summer.
And just so I came back and did it again and then knocked it out the second
time. No problem. Jason Gardener on same thing. He, you know, he,
he's like, yeah, I'm a shot. Fine but failed stalking, telling a kid and,
and then he came back on again and was talking about,
well he talked about some of the mistakes he made and it was very similar to
what you said, but yeah, they would tell them like, hey,
figure out where you're trying to get to and actually analyze the situation
before you start moving. And of course when he was younger he was just new,
I'm just going to go. Yeah.
And so we just went and he would make it in time or people would see him.
So yeah, that's talking thing is no joke out.
But the second time was complete opposite. I think I just relaxed. I said,
you did, you go, did you, when did you go through it? The second time? When did,
when did you go back for stocking? Right before I think we deployed. Yeah.
Right before we deployed. Some time during that same workout. Yep. Oh, okay.
That's cool. That's awesome. Pass it right back. But yeah,
I think I just relaxed and I got there and knocked them all out.
Had all you have to get points for people that don't know,
we build up points says you stock or whatever. So the last,
I think couple of stocks, I'd already had all my points.
So I'm trying to help other guys, you know. That's cool. You know? Yeah.
Looking back, I'm like, man,
I should have really helped with these people or should they have, you know,
should I have gone back to my seat with my buds thing like,
but you're different. It's how would you help them?
Like by trying to distract the instructors or by finding that, uh,
that LP,
but you have to crawl and get within a certain distance and then let them know,
hey, no, you're too far. You're too close. I'm risking like, oh,
there it is. So he didn't have to risk and that sort of thing. So, um,
should I have done that? Maybe not, but uh, anyway, but,
and it gave me good practice too, cause I got to push the limits then,
which gave me a lot of confidence in what I was going to do later.
That's pretty awesome. And then I paid for myself to go to some, uh,
some urban sniper course at Pendleton, some, uh, you know,
one of these kind of fly by night operations that was going on back then, uh,
to teach people how to do with whatever.
So I went to an urban sniper course that I paid for,
cause I was curious that at the time snapper school. So, uh,
I got to learn about urban hides and, and all that sort of thing,
which was pretty cool. Sweet. Who's running it? I forget the name of it.
I think it had like people were they former former marine snipers.
I think they were out with foods at Pendleton.
I guess it probably was some connections there or something. Exactly, exactly.
So, and then the, and free fall too. And free fall was a crazy one cause, uh,
that was, um, I came back to the team one day and I didn't,
I didn't get free fall right away.
I did sniper school and then usually kinda like one or the other, um,
for a new guy coming back. Um, and so,
so my friends went and I came back from,
and this was the first time that they'd done the civilian, uh,
deal where they were training. Oh, okay. Whoever that was. And, uh,
so came back from lunch, he was like, you're back and you're kind of,
people are going to schools and it's, you know,
so the people that they can leave or whatever got married. Um,
and so I came back and I see you Andy stone, who, you know, and, uh,
he's got this look on his face. And I'm like, oh, that's weird.
I parked my truck and you know, there's no, no gate guard at the time.
You drive onto base, remember that? Um, and told us everyone,
one of our dear friends had had a, I'd burned in and died, uh, in freefall,
like in that first week. And, uh, I was like, and then of course,
what does the team do after at night? You, I go to the family, we're, you know,
dear friends and do the whole, all that stuff is my first experience with that.
And so as a team do, oh,
you're going to free fall like a week later after the funeral, I'm like, Dang,
okay, let's do it. So, uh, so yeah. When did the huma, not though civilian one,
but went to, went to you must stopped at Brag first for the, for the air tunnel.
Let the thing that they did back then, the wind tone. Oh, that's cool. Then, uh,
not be Uma. So did those before my, uh, my second platoon.
And then you go into your second, you go on your second deployment. Yup. Yeah.
When did you go on deployment? So a couple of weeks before September 11th. Yup.
So, uh, Guam expecting a, uh, like the first one just stay.
We're gonna go train some people and finally get to go to Thailand. Uh,
and yet two weeks into it, September 11th happened,
people start banging on doors up and down the barracks.
We didn't have TVs in our room then. So, uh, you know,
phones are ringing cause it's midnight I guess in warm and uh, you know,
9:00 AM on the east coast and we all get up and go down to the basement of the
barracks in Walmart.
We had one TV and we all watched the twin towers falling TV.
And I was the Intel guy too, so I was comms and Intel. And so I'd been reading,
I just, you know, read a, what are the bin Laden book was, or previous year,
the man who declared war on America or it was called. And so I was doing,
I was always reading this stuff. I was always fascinated by it.
I was always reading about terrorism,
insurgencies and where to make myself the best seal I could possibly be.
So I knew what I'll kind of mint, you know, I knew what meant the base. And um,
so I gave a brief right away and nobody knew that. I remember the CEO of,
of Guam had no idea who all kind of was. And, uh,
so I gave my brief, and you obviously studied it ever since,
but um, that was, we thought we'd be on planes the next day that this is on,
let's go. And we start palletizing, getting ready, uh,
but really took couple of weeks. And then off we went.
And that's when I did the shit boardings. Um,
cause we took over for team three who went into Afghanistan and we ended up
taking their ship boarding mission,
which actually looking back was a good one because that was my only ship
boarding experience.
And it was interesting because it's like a cop pulling over,
pulling over someone in the middle of the night and you don't know what you're
walking up on who have no idea. And instead of a car in a cop, this is a, uh,
a class three tanker and it's hidden for Iranian waters and you have a certain
amount of time to get on there and turn it around. And you know, as an e five,
I'm turning around a class three tanker using my gps and a compass,
turning this thing around. It was always pretty cool doing that.
And there's some good coordination that has to happen on those sorts.
As a calm guy, you're,
you're working with a bunch of different networks and young and you're,
did you end up, yeah.
Well you just said you end up a lot of times being the person that knows how to
work gps cause you're the calm guy. At least it used to be that way.
Now everybody, that's all they know. Now everybody knows how to do it. But yeah,
actually map and compass. That's why when I later on jumping ahead,
I had to relearn map encompass cause I got so dependent on GPS and there was a
book, I think it's called a bee expert with map and compass.
So when I took over the junior officer training course before I got out, um, we,
I really a nap
course that we did and topic of course the map and compass exit.
So I was a calm guy and when we first started getting issued,
this was in like 92, we first started getting issued the big gpss and they were,
they were like the size of a route and they were big.
They were like the size of two shoe boxes, baby number. They were big.
The PSN eight with this big giant antenna that was like the size of my water
bottle. But, but what was interesting is they say, okay Jocko, you know,
you gotta figure out how to work this thing.
So I figured how to work it and though I said,
well all it does is tells us where we are. And they're like, yeah. And I said,
who, if we have a map and compass, we're good.
Like I know where we are on a map and compass for sure. I'm like,
I know out at sea it's different than when you're,
once you get over the horizon. But anyways,
so it was kind of always surprising to me that it's so much easier if you do a
good terrain study,
you can just walk and you can look at your compass occasionally and you know
where you are at rather than constantly looking at a gps and getting your night
vision trashed from that or whatever. You just just was a different transition.
I mean, and then obviously gps became so good that, yeah, I mean they're,
they're pretty awesome. Everyone has on their watch. Yeah.
Pretty awesome now.
But I did like the map and compass stuff cause I grew up doing it in the,
in the Sierras. I grew up backpacking and an item. But before I can't,
after college I went to Alaska for three months and backpack around up there.
Today I did a national outdoor leadership school up there. And once again,
training, getting ready. You are so ready for that.
I went to high school. That's what I did.
Then I just go this, it doesn't matter. You know, it's all the metal part.
Doesn't matter how much you prepare, how little prepare, it's all he wanted.
If your average athlete and you want this thing, hey, just don't quit.
You'll learn along the way.
You'll get in better shape when you start running and that sand just don't quit.
That sand will get you in a good run, in shape.
So at what point did you put in for an officer package?
So that spring before the September 11th deployment, um, it was, uh,
we had a, let's say a chief that was interesting, a leadership team,
I'd say that was interesting. Um, and you know, the,
the e five mafia was not happy. Um, they were, and it was, um,
it's one of those things like, Hey,
I can complain about it like everybody else or I can put in this package and uh,
and go and do it better than it was done for me. So, so that's what I did.
And you got picked up first time? Yeah. Oh,
you already had a college degree and all of that.
Yeah. So put in, they didn't put pronounce. Got My, I remember there's,
I won't say who he is cause I think he's a, an admiral now,
but he was an XL at the time and I'm going in for my interview and it was a
Friday afternoon. So Friday afternoon, team five workout included a keg and a,
so, you know, I didn't, I did the workout, but then I changed into my whites.
So now I'm in my whites in the spring and those things are horrible.
I hate those uniforms, but, so I'm in my whites, getting them all perfect.
And I go in to do my interview with the, uh, with the XL at the time,
admiral now. And, uh, he's got a beer in front of him and his PT style,
he's like,
I just want you to know how this is going to go and if it's any indication that
this beer should be an indication of how this interview is going to go.
And I was like, ah, I live, but I was still, you know, do you want me? Yeah,
of course. So it's very bearing the whole the whole thing. Um, but yeah,
of course they, uh, I, I did,
I had a good first two platoons as a new guy with no war going on. Um,
and so I got ya got picked up the first time and then you went to ocs? Oh yeah,
after I got back. So, but of course, September 11th happened and I'm like,
Dang it, I made the wrong choice. Um, cause I,
if where you want to be because you want to be enlisted guy, uh, you know,
it'd be in the fight for awhile first. Anyway. Yeah. So, uh, uh,
but it ended up working out well because I got right back from that deployment,
did well, I did it a little training trip to,
to a place and that was a great experience. And then, uh,
classed up for OCS at a in Pensacola Hertz or cola and did the same things.
Yeah, I do that too. It's awful to do the same things.
We didn't bootcamp fold and underwear folds and tee shirts making our bed, uh,
you know, all of those things that somehow qualify you to lead men in combat.
And uh, then right to the seal teams,
right back to seal teams and ended up at a great team that, uh, kind of re,
well, let's see, I would just come back from another east coast seal team, uh,
having spent almost a year deployed after September 11th and Rod,
his lessons learned back and then he sent me into that team and right down
range. So, uh, as a brand new officer, uh, I was,
I was down range fairly quickly. So timing wise it worked out well for me.
That's, that's beautiful. Yeah.
I can learn to learn a ton on that deployment and then brought that back to my
team and uh, then deployed again, right, right away to Iraq. So I got a good,
then you deployed as an assistant to a competitor. Uh, I was Kinda like a third,
a third, a third,
a third o say your ended up doing a lot of the admin stuff and I used to look in
there a lot. Um,
but that's one was an extra guy essentially that's when a nudge off happened.
So that's when I had probably the most most formative time in uniform was uh,
taking a sniper team into an nudge off. So it's, you know, pitch combat for,
it was a two week campaign,
so it was 11 days and it was one of the first times I think that a,
that we really went to the conventional side and said, hey, how can we help,
you know, we're here to support you in this campaign here.
Here's what I'm bringing to the table, these snipers Jay tax,
we can control aircraft for you, complete preplan air. Um, and,
and this is what we can offer. How can this augment you? How can this help?
And I'm sure it's happened before, but that was the first time that a,
that I was involved in something like that and had a great relationship.
Colonel Rainy was the guy's name. You must be a general now or retired,
probably retired now. Um, but I had a great relationship with him and uh,
we just got after it and for 11 days out there it was great. It was absolutely,
I remember how many team guys did you have with you? And it's six I think.
And then we had some Polish ground guys. Um, and then MARSOC debt one,
cause they were part of that deployment with us was the, it was the uh,
I guess trial run or whatever you call. No,
I saw those got turned over with me in Baghdad.
Cause when you guys got to Baghdad from your team, Yup. You went to Mozel. Yup.
First and I was down to Baghdad doing the turnover with the Marzoc guys,
which I knew a bunch of the more soft guys from the old days of doing shipboard
apoe 97, they were butcher. Awesome guys. Awesome. And then, yeah,
and then I went home and then I guess you came down to Baghdad
right before I went home. Take the PSD thing. They, that mission and yeah.
And while that was going on, while we're standing that thing up,
and I learned a ton there too, cause you're like, uh, what are you,
what are we doing?
We're protecting the interim Iraqi government officials and we're not turning
over with anybody cause it hasn't been done before.
And the last guy before allow, he just got blown up by an IED. Ah, okay,
let's do this. Let's figure it out. And uh, so I mean we,
we started with one computer, uh, and my CEO from team two, and it was,
I was at that computer just like he'd be talking to me,
dictating things and putting together the mission, blah, blah, blah.
And I was just learning and you know, chairman and where I could,
where I thought I could have PTSD got stood up with one computer in one small
office and then it grew into this huge monstrosity. I should eventually became.
Um, but still learned a lot.
But that also meant I was an extra and extra dude as we kind of figured out what
was going on. And then I got to go up and, uh, help out with [inaudible] at one,
cause one of those guys had to go back and do something.
So I got to go up and help them out for a little bit on the Intel side of the
house for a few weeks. And while I was there, that's when the job kicked off.
And they're like, we need snipers.
And so he has grabbed snipers and threw us together. Yes.
Awesome scholar. Yep. I remember the uh, the COO team one.
So he was attached to that Marzoc thing.
So essentially working for team one at the time.
And I remember him distinctly calling me in, cause I was y'all. I was the,
Oh and, and I was taking these guys to do this thing that was kind of ambiguous,
were taking over the city as part of a bigger campaign with, uh, uh, uh, two,
seven calf. And he said, hey, whatever you do and whatever this means,
I didn't really know what it meant. I just nodded. But he's like,
whatever you do, don't go forward to friendly lines. And I was like, uh, okay,
like Rogers, what does he mean?
So within hours of being on the ground and we are pushing forward, taking puss,
pushing the enemy back, going up, getting high ground in,
calling in the Bradleys and Abrams and coordinating all that stuff.
So right away I'm disobeying his order and uh,
and getting the job done because that's what it, that's what it took, you know.
Um, but it was, it was incredible to work with those guys. And um, we,
and it was a hodgepodge of people. It wasn't just two, seven cab,
it was army national guard units. It was air from everywhere. Um,
all coming together,
working together for the first time and making this thing happen and pushing the
enemy back towards the emo Molly mosque,
which is one of the holiest sites in all of Islam. And, uh, and that 11th day,
we, we had that place, all of them in the, my Molly boss.
So we worked every day, we'd push forward a little bit and then go up,
take the high ground. Everybody would come up, we'd do that.
Maybe they'd be there for a day though. The water would come up,
the food would come up, that army logistics train.
We would keep us moving and then we'd push forward again. And, uh,
it was incredible to be part of that and a, you know, help out where we could.
But then of course, we have them right where we want them and, you know,
brand new guy, just want to bomb it. I want to drop a bomb on a human,
Molly mosque. Uh, looking back, you know, that probably not the right decision.
There were not, um, no, no. And, uh,
but without all solders in their old tactic call, but not the best.
[inaudible] no, no, definitely.
Now in hindsight and with what I've studied since, you know,
bombing one of the holiest sites in all of Islam probably was not,
would not have been the right move. So that was, that was denied. Um,
but if I'd dot all solder was in there,
although the Mahdi militia was in there and then they did some sort of a peace
agreement, ceasefire ish thing or whatever.
And then we got to watch them all leave and turn their weapons over to the, uh,
Iraqi national guard or somebody. And that was the end of that. So,
and then we dealt with without repercussions for, oh, for a while. But yeah,
we use the tactical experience. Um,
cause I had to come back and talk about having know sniper weapons systems,
but also being able to have a red dot on those things to clear rooms cause we
were clearing rooms and then using those same weapons systems to set up and, uh,
and do the job. So, uh,
I've got to bring a lot of different ways to make the Hudl to become loopholes
or whatever in the walls and you know, all that sort of thing.
So I've got to bring back and share a lot of that experience.
How much longer was deployment once you got done with that?
I think like a month or so. Okay. So it was Kinda like, eh. Yeah.
You were just like so stoked. Yeah, it was pretty good. And uh, yeah,
it's always a, that was a formative experience. And uh, and then it was a,
they called it, it wasn't the surge,
but in the seal teams we called it the surge.
So we got to deploy a year later instead of a year and a half later.
I was really all that meant, so got to get right back after it, which was so,
yeah, cause then you came home. Yeah.
Now did you get platoon commander was your, your so now, so now I'm on,
now it's second over the assistant, I guess the official assistant my way up.
I'm in charge of what you guys the awesome. That's great. Yeah, it was amazing.
Yeah, you're super stoked. You're like, oh I just had that awesome deployment.
Yep. And now I get to do another assistant platoon commander.
Pretty much no factor.
And this time you've got to do an actual workup where you did a workup the first
time to ish, but I was at that third,
oh so I'll do an admin stuff here and there and it wasn't quite a way it is
today where you're only doing admin stuff.
Is that kind of guy attached to the cast unit head shed or whatever. Um,
but essentially I was doing a ton of the app. You're still doing all the workup?
Yeah. Still work. CQC, you still want them out?
You still want to learn more for not all of them. Oh really? Nope.
Cause I was Whitehead my deployment with east with other east coast team in
there. Uh, I came back,
I didn't hit with Haiti when that went down cause I was an extra guy so I got to
go down there, which was pretty cool. You make a good strapping or hoe,
you're one of those guys that kind of like,
I didn't plan like land that was always kind of like, Oh man, I'm not in a,
you know, I'm not the sec, I'm not an Aos. Good deal.
Dave could be late burger run for his money.
It was not a bad time to be just a dude hanging out. They could grab at anytime.
And of course I'm like, Hey, can you go? Yep. Yeah, of course I can go. Uh,
hey sweetie, I'm leaving this afternoon for me. So you,
so now you're in your, now you're doing an actual workout,
you get to do all the training and then you go on deployment and you go back to
Iraq again. Yup. Yup. And a hit Remati this time. Sweet. So going into her mind,
it's oh five, so five. Yep. Fall of Oh five. And that's where he wanted to be.
And uh,
of course it changes throughout that workout for your own here you go there,
whatever. But, uh, I forget at what time it churned to, you were going to,
to Ramadi now. Um, but that's where he, that's where he wanted to be, you know,
five oh six. Um, and so we got to get in there and you know,
it was interesting cause I forget if it was someone there before us or not.
I can't, I don't know why. I can't remember if there was a Turner,
there must have been somebody, but that doesn't stand out in my head. Anyway.
I think it was a much smaller debt before you guys maybe. Yeah,
maybe that wasn't part of that initial,
that first when the head shed goes over first,
like the head shed went over and then I was the senior guy that came over with
the rest of the guys. So I didn't really do. And when I got, when we got there,
most everyone was gone and it was, it was just time to time to figure it out.
So we got to do a few cool things. Um, uh, like going out with the marines,
dressing up like a marine and getting left behind to do the snipers thoughts,
you know, not, not exactly what you guys did cause you guys really got after it.
But, uh, you know, baby steps, you're right. So it was, uh, you know,
going just going out with the marines in the day, you know, doing those patrols,
like, wait, where this, where the IED threat is high. Um,
and one of the most dangerous cities in the world at the time,
like that was legit. Yeah. That's a good, some evolution.
I'm just being on the base side. I mean,
with mortars coming in at night and I stayed, I didn't stay in that,
that whatever the, the, the building, the building, you know,
I stayed out in the tents of the guys. Yeah. Um, and yeah,
there's nothing there to protect you from the water then like you're just
sleeping and all of a sudden wasn't gonna land on you. Water suck. Yeah. Well,
on the receiving end of you knows, and then you,
and then during that deployment as well, you also went to Baghdad and,
and work with an Indian force there. Yep. Yep.
So that's why I didn't see you and turnover, um, got to do this.
The second thing in my time in the military that was the most formative and
yeah. Go do some stuff. Uh, in Baghdad with a [inaudible] basically. Yup. Yup.
Doing that with the more of a civilian type organization and uh, yeah,
with a little less, um, I guess oversight I say.
So I loved it because it fit my personality in my, uh, my drive I guess.
Like I was a perfect fit for me at that time. Um,
and actually one of the things that happened during that time was the
inspiration for the, the second book. One of the guys that I met there,
one of the, uh, Iraqis that I was working with. Um, but yeah, that was,
that was a great time. Learned a ton. We're right there next to, um,
guys from Great Britain, other army guys from their, their uh, the, uh,
I guess Premiere Special Operations Unit. Um,
so when we're doing stuff together and we're training together and uh,
you guys had a really good optempo, if I remember correctly.
It was a good time to be part of that. Yeah. I had a blast doing that.
Learned a ton and I got to stay active. Got To, got to,
got to stay getting after it every, not every night, but you know. Yeah. Good.
Good. OPTEMPO has it Optiv Bro. And then you wrap up that deployment,
which again these are, these are, you've got some choice deployments.
I got a few good ones. Yeah. Was Royce deployments. It was a good time to be in.
My timing was good there, but then I get back.
So now I've done a five deployments in a row. And you're married? I'm married.
Yep. Got Married after that first deployment.
[inaudible] the kid count at this point we are at one. Okay.
One and then uh, two for the next one and then three for the next.
So what'd you do when you got home from that deployment to when you got done
with your assistant platoon commander tour?
So this is where my good deal train ends and uh, I get
back and I've done five deployments in a row. Uh,
if you count the enlisted ones, three is an officer,
all of them get after it and they're like,
you need to go somewhere and get some professional development. Oh yeah.
They did call when to your scan and they out of hope on that there.
Yup. And, uh, semi XO had done a, was the ops had been the op, so in Germany.
So he's like, you need to go to Germany and you need to learn what a unit does.
Like you need to what? Like that's a place to be in 1944,
that's where I want to be, not in 2007. And uh,
so I went kicking and screaming and I probably should have just said Roger that,
you know, but a, you know, five appointments in a row.
And those last three being fairly intense, uh,
I didn't want my guys to go back without me, you know, I felt like you're,
I'm abandoning them to go to Germany and go like taste wine and look at like
castle walls and these different towns like that. No. Um,
but you got to go. Um, but since I'd worked with that other government agency,
um, I got a kind of, I guess you'd say recruited by them.
And while I'm waiting to go to Germany,
I go up to DC and do my bunch of tests that they put you through up there and
uh, get a class update to go to a, to that organization. And, uh,
so I get to Germany, I'm there for a few months. It's horrible. Um, I uh, I,
well they sent me to French language school first cause they thought I was going
to go to North Africa, west Africa. How long was French language school?
Six months. Six months. Um, that was actually good. And you good, whatever,
good family time, all that stuff. But I still wanted to be Iraq rough, you know,
straight up DLI and straight up DLI Monterrey. Yup, sure. Yup.
Luckily I was at an off site so I didn't have to go on base. So that was the,
that was good. So I guess, I guess those are good. Yep.
And of course now I find out about crossfit.
So I found out about crossfit and Ramadi.
So now I'm just crushing the crossfit and people think I'm insane. Um,
cause no one really had seen that yet. It was 2006, 2007 and they're like,
especially outside of the seal teams or outside of, you know,
firefighters and all that stuff, just the regular gym.
They see you're doing all the swinging barbells around like their kettle bell or
whatever. Um, so,
so I'm getting in shape and I'm training for my next whatever deployment.
I'm trying to make myself better. Um, but we go to Germany, get there, hate it.
A lot of people that were loving it and that made me hate it even more. Um,
and I probably, you know, I probably should've just said,
this is where the government needs me,
so I'm going to do the best I can while I'm here. And I did the best I could,
but you're not doing anything. It was awful. Um, I shouldn't say that.
It was a very important place to be and they have a mission and it's great,
but it wasn't for me. Um, so I dropped my papers to get out to go to that. Uh,
cause I was wanting to get back to what I was doing in Iraq and Baghdad in 2006
getting it. And, uh, so dropped my papers and just gonna go,
just get out and go do that. And, uh, then a few weeks later they call me,
the CEO called me back in. And so I say there was, uh,
an OIC at team seven got out, there's a spot open. Do you want it?
And I was not expecting that at all. And I said, Whoa, I have,
my mind was already set. I was, I was essentially mentally, I was out,
I was training, I was getting ready for, to go back down range with this other.
And uh,
so went home, talked to my wife, she was pregnant again with number,
our second child. And we decided to stay. And I'm like, okay, I can get, uh,
get back after to do that leadership role that, that, uh,
that I became an officer to have.
And we went team seven. And that's where I met you.
So now I get my first taste of Jocko and uh, some finally some, uh, uh,
actual professional development that mattered. And uh, it, uh,
up until that point it's baptism by fire. Like show up a team to, hey,
you're going to Afghanistan. Oh No,
no training other than the tee shirt folding and a and underwear folding hit
ocs. Um, luckily I had some really good guys on those deployments that, uh,
had already been to Afghanistan that took me under their wing that, uh,
you know, showed me how, here's how these nods work.
The point man only had them in your last platoons, uh,
before September 11th tears. I use these things. Yeah.
And that's kind of the way it used to be. You,
it was OJT and the young junior officers, or even the young enlisted guys,
you'd just get trained by the more experienced guys.
And that works great if you're lucky enough to have a good experience guy that
has the desire to teach you that really cares about the job,
that wants to do a good job,
that recognizes the importance of leadership and the then, then it works fine.
Yep. The problem is that's, that's not, it doesn't always work like that, right?
You get a guy that's a knucklehead, you get a guy doesn't care, you just,
you can just end up in a bad situation. And then, and then some young kids,
we're young, we're influential,
what clothes we're, we're,
we're very easily influenced now and we see how a bad leader acts and they tell
us that that's how we're supposed to act. And we start acting that way.
It's very, I've seen that happen many times. I'd meet a guy,
I'd meet a guy that would be coming through my training and like,
he wouldn't quite be a good leader. And I, you know,
I'd say it'd be just be talking to him like, Oh,
who was your platoon chief when you were a new guy?
And they'd name a guidance saying, okay, well I,
you could very easily find the root problems here. Right? Or I'd get a young,
oh, I'll get a platoon commander. And I'd say, well, who was your, you know,
who was your platoon commander when you were at AIC?
And they'd give a name and they, the guy would be a bad leader. And you'd say,
okay, well I know where you got this from.
And they give me the ability to actually steer them in the right direction and
say, hey, you know, I wouldn't be offensive about their old boss or anything,
but I'd start like saying, hey, there's another way to look at these things. So,
yeah, sure. Yep. No, it sounds like you got lucky. You had some good leadership.
I mean, I know who your CEO was a team too. He's freaking outstanding. Yep.
And yeah, so you had some good [inaudible], some great mentorship,
cared about it, and he cared about mentors for sure. Um, and his,
the senior guys that he brought with him from his other command also cared about
those senior chiefs.
They cared about what the next generation of both enlisted and officers were
gonna do and how they were going to lead. And, uh,
so I was very fortunate to be the recipient of that mentorship and that
guidance. Um, and, uh, and that,
that served me well and I had a good foundation anyway, but, um, but, uh,
but having that, have somebody cared that
a, the put a little structure, I mean, not, not, no.
A little structure behind it, um, was, uh, was refreshing and uh, yeah,
I just took all that on board and just, uh,
you don't wanna be the best leader I could from for my guys. Um,
but now a team seven. So that's now it's, well, we won't, it was a good,
it was a great experience as an OIC, but most of that was due to the,
the training that you brought. And, uh,
so now I've got to professionalize things a little bit. Think about them.
And now my deployment, my good deal train, I thought ended. Um,
and it spiked a little bit and we thought, oh, we're going back to Afghanistan.
Yes. And it's gonna be you guys, cause you got anybody in,
it didn't end up being my platoon. Um, so I got to go to the Pi,
got to go to the Philippines. And at first I'm like, Eh, that's a bummer.
But it ended up being a great experience, uh, at an outstation had more,
uh, special forces guys working for me than I had seals working for me. Um,
I had multiple outstations that, uh, that reported to me and, um,
and we were there to assist, this has been type thing,
but it was with a Philippine Marine general and he'd been down there fighting
that and certainly in the southern island chain since he was, uh,
an incident or whatever they, you know, I'm a second lieutenant there. And, uh,
I know,
so I took the role of a student with him and amazing guy and just,
I really learned the area, learn what they were up against,
learn how the enemy was adapting to them, um,
and how to change over his 30 some years of doing that.
And of course he was mentored cause they'd been doing that for over a hundred
plus years. They'd been fighting that thing. Um, so he was a recipient of,
of mentorship and lessons from the people that came before him. And, uh,
I took that time because I noticed that the SF guys, the army SF guys,
particularly the warrant officer that was there with me,
knew a lot more about counterinsurgency than I did.
Like I had the tactical kicking the door. I had that experience,
but I didn't have that broader piece yet.
And so I took that time in the Philippines to study and read a ton.
And who are the, who are the foremost experts on counterinsurgency out there?
Where are they? How do I get in touch with them?
Do they have anything I can read? And so I just really schooled myself up.
And so it became a kind of a competition, uh,
between me and him and discussions about counterinsurgencies worldwide,
but particularly where we are, but how that applies more broadly. Um,
so I took it as a time to a, and, and we did get to go do,
they got to do some things down there that film, film, marines with us, just,
uh, you know, helping with some more technical things. But, uh, but we,
they got to get after it and they lost guys and we were there doing the,
the Medevac and doing all that sort of thing. Um, you know,
the bodies lined up the whole deal. Um, and it was a, so it was, uh, it was,
it ended up being a very, um, I, I guess a,
a another formative experience for me.
And then I got to use what I learned about working with the army once again.
But, uh, in my next deployment as a troop commander, once again,
I had and went back to Iraq and had more SF guys working, uh,
under my man than, than I had seals. So it was good. It's a good run.
So you, you went through workup when you were a platoon
commander in 2008. Eight, Yup. Cool. Yeah,
so I was pretty settled in because I'd come home in 2006 and 2007 I took over
the training. So yeah, we were, we were, we were going hard.
Oh yeah. Oh yeah, yeah. My first experience, I heard all about this Jocko guy,
why, who is this guy? And, uh, and uh, the first time I met you,
you walked in to that room,
that briefing room at Fort Knox of the stadium seating and they have them
diagram of things over the sand table stuff, Huh? Yeah. And uh, yeah,
you came in and gave us this, this talk and I was like, yeah,
let's go get it. It was awesome. But uh, I had one of my more formative uh,
experience in training in that particular, um, uh,
urban warfare environment thing where I, you probably remember the,
the scenario cause you probably did it for her for most of the platoons and
troops coming through,
but you have a mission and you go out there and you're doing that mission and on
the ground force commander now the GFC and I'm there in my,
in my vehicle and helicopter crashes like a few buildings down a few blocks down
and a that comes over there where they're radioing for help for a couple of
blocks away. And we,
we still have guys in the building and our guys are taking contact in the
building and it's all set up, whatever. And I'm like,
I'm hearing that and I'm not going, I'm not going to,
I'm going to deal with this problem first when to prioritize and execute. Sure.
Yes. But I wasn't quite doing that yet. I was like, why'd you,
I'm listening to the radio and I'm hearing they have a woman with the screaming,
a helicopter pilot, females screaming like, ah, they're surrounding us.
What about the whole thing? And like, ah, what do I do? Ah,
and I split my force. Oh yeah, I split my force. Oh yeah. And uh,
so hey, these two vehicles breaking off, you're gonna go to the crash site,
secure the crash site will then meet you at that crash site and we'll exfil
together. So you know what happens next? Yes, I do. Disaster, disaster strikes,
everything goes. So I, and that was the point of the exercise.
I think if you split your force, that may matter what happens every time.
But it, but uh, in this case it did was it ended up being a disaster.
We get out, we, there's guys behind. We have to go back in the whole thing.
It was, it was great. It was great, but, uh,
I remember sitting down with you afterward and it really drove home,
prioritize and execute. And, uh, if you split your force,
you better have a damn good reason to split that for us. Just
had a, a guy named John Stryker Meyer on the podcast, the last podcast,
you couldn't have heard it yet because it's not out yet,
but he's telling a story. He's in Vietnam and this guy's just incredible sock,
just the most insane stories ever. And he's telling a story and he goes, yeah.
So I split my forces and I put, you know,
four guys on one side of valley and four guys on the other side of the valley
and we start moving it. And I, and I had to like find out bro,
cause I mean like this is, this is disturbing to me. Right. And so I said,
I was like, explain to me, you know, what,
what made you decide to split your forces? I said, I never liked it. He goes,
I never, he goes, I split no this way. He said, he goes,
I split my force to two times in Vietnam.
Other than that it's horrible idea cause I didn't even like doing it here.
I didn't have a choice. So that is a true statement. That is a true statement.
If you can avoid splitting your forces, avoid flooding,
splitting your forces and if you have to, you better have a damn good plan.
You've ever damn good reason. Because when then when you add enemy fire into it,
trying to link up forces friendly forces under enemy fire,
I believe that's the hardest thing to do in combat.
I think that's the hardest thing to do in combat is separate forces.
Trying to link up with enemy contacts is a freaking nightmare.
And so if you can avoid it, avoid it. Yep. You have had to do that. Yeah.
Baghdad once with a QRF that we,
I just talked to on the radio before and ask that was a little little dicey.
But um, but yeah, that the not splitting your forces for our ties and executing.
I'll never, never forget that and never forget that experience.
And luckily up until that point,
I hadn't been in a situation where I had to do it down range because I probably
would've done it. Um, but after that training, I, I was like, I would,
I would think, I think long and hard, maybe not long and hard, I would think,
uh, think it through before doing that. Yeah. Tough move to make. Yup.
That was a great one
for me. Coming back from Ramadi, I was like super, um,
paranoid about stuff and really into the fact that like,
I wanted people to not make dumb mistakes that I made or that I could have made
or that I saw other people make. Like, so I was pretty, um,
adamant to make sure the guys were learning lessons.
Oh yeah. No, it was a, it was amazing that that training was great.
And then we went to Niland of course,
and did the Philando warfare thing and I was very comfortable with that because
we had a team on the east coast. We'd done that. Uh,
I EMT individual movement technique, uh, earlier on,
I guess maybe on the West Coast.
So I had it died down at a couple of times already.
So some of my junior officers that, uh,
had never done it before and they were like, what are we doing? Why are we,
it's not just just online and just the old school. Um,
so they didn't quite quite get it, but I was a platoon commander.
I was very comfortable with that at Nyland. So, um, and it was, it was, yeah,
obviously amazing training, especially with the technology that's, uh,
that came along at that time where there was no,
there was no hiding from any mistakes that you might've made out there.
You got the GPS on you and you go back and you debrief it.
There's none of that old school nineties. Like, no, that wasn't me.
I think it was so and so over there. I would never do something like that.
Oh No. Here it is. Here's your number or whatever it was on there. And,
and you can watch it all in the debrief room and watch your little watch,
your little, uh,
your little what's icon or still icon around field and watch your little icon
engage your own forces. Oh yeah. Watch that over, over do it. Right. Yep.
No, exactly. And then going through the second time, you know,
things evolve and change and, and all that. But uh,
going through the second time as a troop commander then I was even more
comfortable with it, particularly in those those situations.
I knew the lessons we wanted to get out of there. Um, and uh,
then I could do it a little better even than when I was a platoon commander
cause I'd already learned some of those in those scenarios.
But uh, yeah, and that was a amazing training and there was no,
there is no question, uh, the, the impact that has had on the,
on the seal teams for them in a positive way carried some down. Ben, did you,
that was awesome. Yeah. Yeah. Everybody, everyone's down. Everybody. Oh my gosh,
yes. A lot of down mandrills it was a lot of that. I mean especially,
and then what was cool for me and people always remember that but,
but when they talk to me about it and, and sometimes even then, you know,
this is too much, you know. And the fact of the matter is if you,
if your leadership did a good job inside of a task unit or inside of a troupe,
if the leadership did a good job and the,
and the use decentralized command and the fire team leaders got up and made
things happen and they kept thinking like if they did those things,
you couldn't, we the trade at guys, the treat at cadre couldn't take,
they couldn't,
they couldn't put a bunch of people down cause they would get their asses kicked
by the troop, the troop would crush them. And you know,
that would usually not happen early on cause they would have to figure this out.
But once they got good at it, like the trader guys would say, you know,
they'd be calling up myself for the or the master chief running it and be like,
Hey, can you bring me back to life? Can you bring back to life? And be like,
no man, you, you know, you got killed. Of course,
sometimes we would bring them back to life to press the platoon harder.
Of course I'm not,
I'm not going to claim that we didn't do that because we're going to put the
pressure. Yeah. Yeah. But uh, yeah, so that was amazing.
The down mandrills yeah. I get you get you in shape and then, but then it,
it gets people pissed off.
Like I came back to life and you're pissed and you're not making good decisions.
Yeah, totally.
And the other thing that you taught me and I passed on and they'd say,
I still think about today and it's not, it gets in the book, uh, you know,
take a breath, look around, make a call, as easy as that,
they say that, that I think about that a lot. Like, oh, I got to do,
sit back and get off my gun,
look around what's going on with the sac tactical situation and make a call.
That's it. So simple. So not easy.
So, not easily do, but it's cool when someone like,
like for someone like yourself that's a sniper that likes to shoot and all of a
sudden you're tasking to commander,
it's real easy to get to go right back to what you're super comfortable with,
which is, hey, I'll just get on my gun and start killing bad guys.
But you've got 40 other guys that are doing that and none of those 40 guys are
actually making a decision about where you're going to go next to save every
one. So you're the guy that has to do it. So that's, so that's a good one. Yep.
For sure. When I look back at old pictures,
I see that how my loadout changed over the years. Uh,
and now five time I was a troop commander, you know, my,
I'm a lot lighter while I'm radios now too. And you're carrying
mags. I'm like, ah,
the only thing y'all three and one of the gun or whatever it was.
But there's a reason for that is cause that my job is not a control this element
and crush the enemy not to be on the trigger. And then, uh, what was your,
what was that deployment like where'd you go as a, to you commit?
That was interesting because it was the, a, it was the withdrawal from rack, so,
uh, were there six months. Um, but, uh,
it was because we didn't know if we're staying, if we're going, if
we're staying or authorities, we're going to be, um,
where we were going to be based. Uh, there was a lot of questions. Um,
so we had to prepare both to stay longterm and to get up, pack and come home.
Uh, which is what ended up happening. Uh, so I think we got, they made us,
our element actually ended up going to the Aleve and at the end of November,
I guess there was another month there, but it was getting,
they packing up and going home essentially. Um,
but you're working with a partner force and you're using your, uh,
technical intelligence to try to prosecute targets so that, uh,
this wasn't gonna become a highway of death on the way out of there as the enemy
just sets. I did you drive out of there? No. [inaudible] throughout. I was,
they drove out pretty peacefully to not a big massive convoy. Exactly.
It was not, uh, now what we expected. So,
but it was cool for a little bit cause you got, I think they,
they got a little more liberal with some of the targets there for awhile when
they were like, okay, we don't want this highway debt.
That's not going to be on really,
because I denied that I didn't want to let a unilateral op go when we're leaving
anyway. Uh, so, so it got a little, we got to do a couple of obs, but uh, but,
uh, mostly it was, uh,
a leadership challenge to keep the guys focused on their mission while at the
same time getting ready to go home for almost the entire deployment.
So it was an interesting time. That was Bosnia southern racks.
I hadn't been down there before the Brits had been there first. Of course,
I'm totally different terrain than anything I had dealt with before. And uh,
it was, but it was good. It was an interesting deployment.
Had a great a senior chief. Um, and, uh, he was still in,
he was still in crushing it and yeah,
came home and that was the last time I'd ever tactically lead guys on the
battlefield.
And I knew that and pretty much as soon as we were airborne on the way home,
like getting out. It's a, so that was, that was many years.
Were you out at that point? I think I was at 16. Right there.
And what was your family situation at this time? So three kids and right at the,
during the second worker, so or so in my OIC work up, uh,
the one where I met you and then went to the Philippines, um,
that's when our middle child was born and we found out,
I think it was at the month checkup that something wasn't quite right. And, uh,
he ended up, well, I'll get to where he has, but we couldn't,
didn't know what was going on. I wasn't eating, um, wasn't meeting milestones.
There was something off and my wife knew right away, but it was just like,
I just took just a Keto eat when he's hungry, that sort of thing. Um,
and we didn't know what was happening. So all during that second, uh,
of that deployment,
they put me in that exceptional family member category five cause there was a,
you know, pretty severely disabled and uh,
which means that you're not going anywhere outside of the, your,
your current medical situation for your family. So it essentially takes the,
the decision out of the service members hands, which is a good thing,
meaning you're gonna stay,
you were in San Diego and you're staying with that exceptional service member
thing says, okay, we got to take care of this guy.
He's going to stay in San Diego. Yup. Yeah. There's different levels to it.
But ours was during your second, during your OIC tour or during your,
to compare between the, you can mandatory the first
that we're still trying to figure out what was going on during that first one
and nobody knew what was going on with him. So it's, well it's a lot of,
a lot of doctor visits, all that sort of thing.
But my wife did it all because as you know,
when you're in that pendulum has to be on the team,
that's your responsibility as a leader. You're, you owe it to the,
to the mission. You owe it to the guys, you owe it to their families,
you go to the country ultimately to have that be your sole focus. Um,
and that's how it was. The pendulum is over there and my wife got that, um,
uh, that, that's, that's what you do as a leader obviously. So when I got back,
well, yeah, when I got back, we still don't know.
So now I've done two workups with this situation,
two deployments with this situation. My wife's handled it the whole time,
super strong. Um, get back and I go to buds as the Oxo,
so I get to see people ring the bell outside that office and put the,
put the helmet down. Um, but in my head,
I know I'm done and I haven't w I didn't make a, I didn't hide it.
A lot of guys will hide it if they're planning on getting out.
They won't say anything to anybody in the chain of command because they might
stay in or whatever it is. Uh, but I'm like, Yep, I'm getting out. That's funny.
And they're like, no, you gotta go be an ex now and not at 20. And uh,
it kind of surprised people when I'd say that. Um,
but buzz is a machine that is running and as an op, so it's fairly,
I dunno, it's not as dynamic, let's say. Is that at a seal team? Um,
and is during that, well,
little after that that someone told Ross Perot our story,
the Ross Perot and in Texas and the guy and so about your son. Yep.
About our son. Cause you still didn't know what was going on. Right?
So this is six years into a bunch of different hospitals. You know,
these six years old, you have no idea what's happening.
All sorts of different diagnosis, uh, to, uh,
paid for Cedar Sinai going up there where we thought we're the foremost experts,
um, to oxygen. My wife would take him to an oxygen tank 30 days,
two hours a day or whatever it was that we paid for,
just to see if anything would, would help. Um,
someone tells Ross Perot Her story,
and this is December of 2013 I want to say.
Um,
and I get a call out of the blue from Ross Perot who sounds exactly like Dana
Carvey impersonating Ross Perot in the 90s. And, uh, like what is going on?
And he's like, I'm going to, we're gonna fix your son. Like what? Uh, what?
And he's like, yeah, I want to send the, send the jet,
I'm going to assemble a team of doctors here in Texas and we're going to fix
him. And then he hangs up like, what just happened? That was wild.
And about an hour later,
his Lee doctor at southwestern medical center calls and says, Hey,
I know Mr [inaudible] just called you. Uh,
we're not gonna send the jet tomorrow, but we are going to send it.
And in the meantime,
send us everything you have on your son and any medical records and we'll
assemble a team of genetic specialists here that we'll take a look at everything
and we'll bring you guys in for some testing and see what we can do. It's like,
wow, amazing. So a month later, um,
they send the jet you five 50 lands and we get on and head off to Texas and go
to a week of testing in Dallas.
And they sent our blood all around the world and found a genetic specialist in
the Netherlands who had just discovered the certain genetic mutation that helps
form the brain at birth.
And that now it has a name to it and it's the three doctors that discovered
this. But when, uh, when we found out about he was the 13th person in the world,
so number 13 in the world they found with this,
and it was just called an r two f one, which is the,
the gene that this mutation affects. And uh,
being able to put a name to it for us, especially for my wife,
that was so liberating. Um,
I can't really describe what it means just to put her name to it.
It seems like a simple thing,
but a not knowing for six years and then being able to put a name to it and know
that, hey,
this is just one of those random freaky things that happens and there's nothing
you could have done about it. And that's it. Just dub.
We got to put a name to it. So it was like Roger that, okay, uh,
now what do we do? And, uh, for us, that's our mission in life. You know,
he gave us purpose and that purpose and mission is to make sure that, uh,
he reaches his full potential, whatever that may be, but he needs 24,
seven fulltime care for life. So, um, uh,
and we have two kids bracketing him on, on either side.
So the real challenge is raising those kids so that their childhood is not
solely defined by their brother's condition. And, uh,
hopefully it makes us all more loving, more compassionate people.
And so far it's, it's worked out that way. But once again,
my wife still bears the brunt of that every day cause I'm out here, you know,
I'm a, I haven't had a nice dinner last night. I'm here hanging out with you.
Um, and she's at home.
The only thing I sound like the bad guy or let's just say I go on book tour,
I'm a dad, go on for two weeks, a book tour and a, you know,
I'm shaking hands and all that. And she's, uh, she's got it, you know, the,
the wives that the wives are incredible. You know, mine included,
she raised four kids and you know, I was barely ever around. So, um,
and you know,
same thing with every guy that we have on here that talks about what their wives
had too. And I think Jason Gardner, when he was on,
he said he, the first time he was on, he said, put up with his wife,
had to put up with a lot. And then he came back on and said like,
he didn't mean it like that.
It's like actually had the strength to handle what the appropriate statement is.
Hey, you know, the wives, the wives that stick around. Yep.
Which isn't a big number, right? Most,
most women don't have the strength to get through this and deal with this kind
of thing. But you know, obviously your wife is a saint and as his mind and like,
okay, you're going to be gone all the time. Cool. I got this,
I'm going to handle it. So, and that's how it has to be.
So now hopefully the pendulum is not quite like this. You're like,
I'm not dealing with life, life and
death situations. Um, so I can, I can help out a little more, but I'm still,
yeah,
there's an entrepreneurial type venture writing is not just a writing in a cave
somewhere and sending it off to New York.
It's everything that goes along with building a small business.
So right now it's a, it's a full on sprint. We have momentum and a,
I don't really have any other speed besides just all in.
So a is are building this thing and,
but it's not like you're deploying for six months, although things do shift now.
So now, uh, even a,
like a two week trip that that's like a six month deployment relatively now.
Cause there's not the country asking you to do this. You don't, uh,
you don't owe it to the guys or the mission anymore, uh, type thing. But, uh,
yeah, no, I'm super, super fortunate to have the wife that I do.
She's so strong and um, yeah, our son is,
so he's 11 now and really has a mental capacity by a two year old I'd say.
And, um, but with only the, so few people in the world diagnosed with this,
I think now they're probably up to must be in the 70s now. But, um, uh,
you know, uh, it just, every day.
So every day is still a struggle. And uh, but that's our mission. You know,
we got him for a reason and that's, I look at it has a,
we got him because we're strong enough to, uh, to handle it. And that's,
I don't know how else you'd have. How's he do? Look at it. I don't really know.
And then so as this is going on,
was that one of the things that made you think about getting out of the
[inaudible]?
Oh yeah.
So I didn't think about it while I was doing that OIC platoon or doing my troop
commander to work cause I was just all in. Um, but once I got back,
like when that plane took off, when we landed in San Diego,
when I took a breath, realize I'm going to buds,
I see people guys running on the beach, you know, doing the,
doing the buds thing. Um, that's not why I came in. Um,
I came in to do the job, I'd done the job. Now I owe it to my family to, uh,
to let that pendulum go back and take care of them.
So it was very obvious to me. It wasn't like, it wasn't,
it wasn't something I struggled with. Uh, I think a lot of guys like,
should I get a stay in? Should I get out? Uh,
what's my hard time with that transition? Mine was not difficult.
Neither was the decision to get out because I was handed my next mission.
Really. We just didn't care of the family and especially our middle child. So,
um, in that respect, my transition, um, easy is the wrong word, but,
um, I knew what I needed to decision was clear. There was no, no wavering.
And then you knew from your previous,
from your childhood that the job you were going to take,
the job you're going to go after after you retired was going to be a writer.
Yep,
Yep. And of course, you can't say that,
especially at that time in the CLT teams, like, you know, the, uh,
the midline and stuff is going on and all that. So, uh,
that's when I played very close to the chest, I say, uh, to the best. Um,
so I knew what I wanted to do my whole life.
I didn't think about it while I was in the teams. It was just like,
that's what I'm going to do next. Yeah.
That's the amount of thought I put into writing when I was in the teams. Um,
but everything that I read growing up was part of that education.
All the reading don fiction that I did on insurgencies and terrorism, um,
all that fed into it. Then all the personal experience down range.
So it's almost like, um,
I could not be more prepared for what I'm doing now as a writer. Um,
but uh, I didn't during those last couple years, I was just like, okay,
upsold budge then to your junior officer training course OIC, which was great,
but it's only for a couple of months.
But I love that cause you get to pass on some lessons and then you'll move on
out. But that last year in the navy,
and I think I've heard you talk about this before, uh,
and that you didn't do all these things that you're supposed to do when you get
out. Like I had went into the, what are the taps, whatever that course.
It was awful. I could did all those things that you're supposed to do.
Are you even going, I know I heard you say that. I'm like, you could,
how did you get out of that? Well, no one's going to tell you what's, I mean,
you're a big dude. You're not, everyone's going to tell you, you gotta do this.
But, uh, I went,
I did that course and I went to medical and I went to dental and I got all the
signatures and I got my paperwork in order.
And that was like the whole last year in the navy. Uh, had spine surgery,
had spine surgery in there last year. Yeah. So that was good. Um,
and I still got all that taken, taken care of. Uh,
but it's during that time where I'm like, okay,
my job is to get out of the navy now.
Well now I'm gonna start thinking about it's writing thing. And uh,
that's when I wrote down about seven different ideas. Uh,
I put them on the table in front of me, like one page synopsis type things.
And I chose the one that I thought would resonate with people the most.
And that's that, that theme of revenge cause that's, that uh,
resonated with me as a kid growing up, both in movies and books.
And it's something that just resonates with people in general,
is that theme for whatever reason. So I knew the first book would be without,
would be the theme of the first novel.
And then when did you start actually writing it? During that last year?
Um, so yeah, for outline, uh,
synopsis started writing title came really quickly, all that sort of thing.
Um, but then submitted it.
So I got out summer of 2016 was my retirement and submitted it to Simon and
Schuster in the fall of 2016. And uh,
I got very lucky, very, very lucky in that a,
a friend calls me out of the blue and he says, Hey, do you know this uh,
author Brad Thor? And I said, Oh yeah, of course I know him. And he said, well,
I know you're writing this book. Do you want to, you want to talk to him?
Maybe has some advice for you. I said, well, he talked to me and he said,
let me set it up. Yeah. It's a former CEO who's out in the finance world now.
And they sat next to each other at some fundraiser or something. And, uh,
so I get on the phone with this Brad door guy and he could not have been more
generous with his time. It's Kinda like an interview. It's kind of like a,
why do you want to write type thing. That was the underlying, um,
kind of theme of our conversation.
And I think he wanted to make sure I was doing it for the right reasons and you
know,
told him the truth about my mom being a librarian and reading all this stuff
growing up and all these authors I loved and wanting to do this forever.
And he's like, all right, I'm not going to help you as you go along,
so don't send me chapters, don't ask me questions. Um, but if you read a book,
if you finish a book, I will let Simon and Schuster know that it's coming.
You can't guarantee the open.
It definitely can't guarantee that they'll like it, uh, if they read it. Um,
but as a thank you,
your friend told me some of the things you did in the teams and as a thank you
for that, um, I will let them know it's coming. And I'm like, Roger that.
And he said, what are you going to be done? I said, one year from today, and uh,
call them back one year to the day later. And I was like, Dude, you remember me?
And uh, he sure did. And I said, it's done. And he said, well,
it done the best it can possibly be. I was like, well,
nope, nope. I can still work on it a little more, but it's done. Uh, he said,
well, call me back when it's the best that it can possibly be. And I said,
Roger, that. So it took another four months of reading, editing, rewriting,
getting it to, you know, if you've held onto it for 10 years,
you could probably make it better by degree. But, uh,
I mean it was at that stage where it was ready for another set of eyes and, uh,
called them back four months later and he said, okay,
I'll let my editor know what's coming and shipped it off. And she read it.
Next thing you know,
I'm on a plane to New York and we're having coffee and I think you want to make
sure I wasn't a crazy person. And, uh, she said, hey, I want this thing, but,
but you need an agent. And I'm like, well, how do you get one of those? And uh,
so she introduced me to four agents and then I, uh, I chose one. Next thing,
you know, we're off to the races. So, uh, I, I got very lucky. Yeah,
that's awesome. It does take a little bit of luck. How do you,
how do you actually mechanically, right? Like what do you actually do? Yep. So,
um, all those seven different synopsis that I had ahead of time, um,
where I picked the one,
now all those other ones are turning in to these next novels,
even though I might have different characters or whatever,
I can more for those ones. So I have about seven different novels in,
in the pipe ready to go. So start with that idea, the synopsis,
like a one pager, two pager, then an outline. And then as I write,
I fill in that outline cause new things, I, new ideas come up, new chapters,
new characters and I added to that outline. So the,
and it was in word up until very recently. Um,
and I just of have a visual representation.
What's words you switch to from word to Scribner. Okay.
We shall get to here in a second. Game Changer. Um, so yeah, in words,
you're scrolling and copying and pasting,
moving chapters around and then you know,
you don't want to cut and then have it disappear because it was nervous. Uh,
is it backed up? Oh my God. So, uh, so yeah,
so I'm filling out of that paradigm. Exactly. Don't cut and paste,
I want to cop cop the case. Power goes out at that moment,
it's out something, I hit the wrong thing and it's gone. Uh,
so I fill in that outline until I'd say about 75% and then it becomes not as
efficient for me to continue to just have an outline that's now very complete.
Uh, now I can just transition to just the story about that point. Um,
but you know, recently I found out about this thing,
Scribner and that it set up very much like word, but you,
it's broken down by chapter so you can drag and drop chapters and see how it
looks. You can have each one of those chapters have a synopsis.
So it shows up as essentially like a card or a yellow sticky and you're looking
at this whole thing and think, oh, you know what?
Chapter six should really be chapter three, drag and drop.
And you can move in research so you can drag in articles from online pictures,
video into research folders. So it's all right there instead of like,
what file was that? Did I copy you?
Put where you are like a day late and uh,
eight books too late for me at this point. Seriously.
Like that sounds like brilliant.
And I could so use that and I just finished my eighth book. Nice.
So that sucks. That sounds awesome.
For nine. Yeah. And [inaudible] which I started yesterday.
Yep. Import from words,
I had about half of the import from word and it breaks it into chapters.
You just put an icon and let it know whenever that little symbol is I'm where
you want the chapter breaks and then can you export it back to work.
And I haven't done that yet.
So I will be doing that in the next couple of weeks. Uh, for book three. Uh,
but I have not actually have imported from ward. I have not exported.
So you can say you can. Yup.
They say you can in the tutorial video and they show you how,
but I have not yet done that check. Yeah. From all over it.
Cause my editor likes that word.
So before we nerd out too hard, we'll move on to something else. Yeah.
Uh, so you get done with these and,
and where did you, I mean,
what did you do with your family once you retired because you had the mission of
your kid and your kids, you had the mission,
now that you've got to finish this book,
did you finish that book while you're still active duty? Nope. Nope. Sell,
finished it a just a four months afterwards.
So you set yourself up financially somewhat that you were in a survivable
scenario, even without alternative income besides your retirement.
Uh, I had other, uh,
businesses. You had some other little,
you had some other little side things going on and give you enough money to
float this gig.
Yep. I have an operation in Hawaii, a hunting operation out there, um,
with a couple of other partners. Um,
every so often someone would ask me to do some speaking or whatever. Um,
that sort of thing. Did some, some tactical training, um,
little things like that. But I was set up to, uh,
to be able to move into this financially and then we're, where did you,
where'd you move to?
So we got out and we weren't planning on moving cause our son, we thought, hey,
we have this, uh, the support network built up now over the last six,
seven years. Uh, it's here in San Diego and we can never move. We can't,
we definitely can't go someplace where it's cold because he just lies down.
And just, anyway, it's a,
it would be very difficult to take him to a place where it was rainy,
where it was snowy, uh, where you had to put extra clothes on him and that,
that sort of thing. And then we go to park city, Utah, the a,
the winter after I get out and we took our son on a vacation with us for the
first time and we started going to park city during my last couple of years when
I'm not. So I build up ton of leave. I never took leave, uh,
until those last couple of years. Um, cause I was last couple of years.
I'm like, well, I'm not taking guys down range anymore. Um,
let's start taking some leave. Uh, we have all this on the books. So we, uh,
we'd go to park city with a few friends from San Diego cause it's easier to fly
to salt lake and drive to park city than it was to drive two bands of traffic to
get to a mammoth or big bear or whatever else. So a,
so we started doing that last couple of years and then we took our son on
vacation with us and we took someone with us to help.
So we had an extra set of hands.
But we got there and we spent two weeks up in park city and we thought,
you know what, we can do this. We're not tied to San Diego. Um,
we brought someone, yes, that was your full time. Yes. Um,
but we did it and that was like, ah,
that opened just some few doors for us that we didn't think were open to us
ever. And while we were there, I opened this, open this magazine and say, Hey,
look at this, this house around the corner here, let's go check this thing out.
So we drove around the corner, checked it out and let's move.
We decided right then and there to move and, uh,
got the house and six months later we're there.
And I think it helps to make a physical and psychological break with the
military for me. Um, because I was in Coronado and as the obstacle buds,
I saw so many guys, they couldn't let it go.
And obviously it's a huge part of who I am. It's in my,
my novels and all that stuff. It's a huge part of me. Um,
but I saw guys that kept coming back to buttocks,
kept calling me as the opposite. Hey, can I get a tour?
I want to show somebody around, hey, no problem. Come on in. And you know,
I call them out it, um, but I saw these, couldn't let it go. Um,
going to all the charity events, uh, going to the same bars,
going into the same grocery stores, especially in Cornetto. Um,
so I think for me it was healthy to say that was one chapter of my life.
Obviously a huge influence on me. I wanted to do it my whole life, but now,
now we're moving forward and now there's a new chapter and that's as an author
and that's taking care of my family and raising our kids to be good citizens and
good people. And that's what I'm going to do next.
And I think it just helped to not run into somebody at the grocery store from a
platoon and say, oh, what are you doing? Oh, who's your CEO? What's a, you know,
an all those sorts of same questions. Um, that just keeps that tie.
So being able to say goodbye to San Diego and he was saying,
he goes great to us, love San Diego, love Coronado,
but that was one part of our life.
And our new life is in the mountains raising our kids in a ski town.
And you're super stoked or no? Yeah, love it over there. Loaded up there.
And we got there, we drove, you know,
we'd put at the u hall and we drove through the night and all that.
And we'd get there 13 hours later cause you're chugging along with this you all
and we get to unload it and the next day we go to the grocery store and we look
around and we're like, man, people in Park city are in good shape.
Like we thought we were in pretty good shape in San Diego.
Like these people are insane in park city.
It just draws these people that want to raise their kids in ski towns.
Usually they've done something somewhere else where they, you know,
hit their nose, whatever they, they can live there and they're really in to, uh,
being in shape and, uh, being, you know, the best people physically,
mentally, spiritually, whatever, just being the best,
most efficient people they can be.
And Luckily had some friends up there already and this insane group of guys that
works out in the morning, we wake up at five and uh, once again, that pendulum,
this last few months has been on the writing. But when I first got there,
I start working out with these guys that I knew from before. Um,
and a hope you darling is kind of the lead of that.
It used to be the CEO of Skullcandy and a new CEO, a g or a, he, uh,
has a bunch of other ventures,
but this guy is in insane shape and he's there every morning at five 30 with
some crazy workout,
like picture your hardest crossfit workout and then times it by three or four
had some trail running it. It's crazy. And, uh,
so I showed up with these guys and uh, they're awesome,
but they're all about just human potential,
I think is the best way to put it and maximizing that potential,
whether it's your family, whether it's in business, personally, whatever,
just uh, and,
and staying up to date on the latest and the greatest and testing things out.
And they're, uh, an amazing group of people.
So I'm very fortunate to get to work out and spend time with them.
Cause all high performers, we all push each other. Um,
and even though I'm not the, not the fastest anymore,
certainly not the strongest, especially with this crew, it's, uh,
it's cool to get out there and uh, and then just be, you know, just be together.
That little team. Awesome. Well, I mean it looks like we're at a pretty good,
that's, that gets us to today. You know, where you're at.
Probably a good place to wrap the books.
Tell us just a little bit about the books.
What do we need to know about book one book two? Yeah.
So the first one is the terminal list, which uh,
I didn't say it out loud for about,
for the first year I was working on it and then I said it out loud for the first
time and there's two ELLs next to each other. And I said it for the first time.
I was like, Dang it. Like it's a tough one to say that terminal list. Um,
but a, at it's base level, it is a story of revenge without constraint.
And that's what I wanted to explore. And I think it was,
I adored a team five ops 1997.
I saw there yet someone xeroxed copied a,
a thing from the brand new internet that, uh,
had a picture of a Samurai on it and it said something about a Samurai going
into battle thinking they were already dead. And, you know,
I went back and looked at all my old bus shooto books from high school and
college. And, uh, I thought, Oh wow,
maybe they did that because they thought it made them more effective and
efficient lawyers. Uh, they're going into battle already dead. And I thought,
how do you do that with a modern lawyer?
How do you do that with someone that has a background similar to mine?
So I can explore these feelings and emotions behind different experiences that I
had down range in a completely fictional sense. Um,
but how do I make him already dead?
And then I thought about the church hearings in the late seventies and how the,
uh, the government had tested certain drugs on our nation,
soldiers on a mental patient, mental mental institutions, uh, college students,
um, without a, any review, when,
any sort of structure in place with how that's gonna go down.
And things changed after that. And I thought, well,
what if somebody didn't get that memo?
What if there was something they wanted to test out?
They wanted to test it out on some of our nation's most elite soldiers and then
something goes wrong. Um,
so how do I free this guy up to think he's already dead and come back and have
to use the, um, tactics,
techniques and procedures of the enemy on home soil?
So essentially I wanted someone that thought they were already dead,
that now gets to bring what was so effective against us in Iraq and Afghanistan
to home soil as he works his way up a list,
putting the bad guys in the ground one by one. Um, so that's,
that's really what that first one's about.
And then if you dig a little deeper into it, more, uh,
like psychological wise, I guess it's, uh,
about a veteran that comes home and brings the war from Iraq and Afghanistan
home to people that have been sending young men and women to their deaths for
clothes. Well, coming up on 20 years now, pretty soon. So, uh,
you can read it like that too, but that's, that's deep. That's deep. Uh,
where'd you pick up with true believer? So it's a continuation of the story.
So in high school I saw it's a,
it was on PBS and it was a special with bill Moyers and he had an interview with
a guy named Joseph Campbell who wrote a book called the power of myth and the
hero with a thousand faces.
And I was fascinated by it because why are you wanted to write one day?
And I remember they talked about George Lucas being influenced by this for star
wars and uh, kind of the Samurai aspect of different things.
And then how across culture, the hero's journey is similar,
very similar for the cultures that had never touched each other before.
You know, China, native American, Indian, Africa, northern Europe,
they all had this similar journey.
And usually it's a reluctant hero that goes on a journey, emerges,
transformed at the end of that journey. Um, so that was a big influence. So,
and writing these you have go Mikey, in the dragons on it.
I was just reading that to my kid the other night. And uh, yeah, so he,
so he has to go, you got to go into the cave and you have to emerge transformed.
But how do you do that with one book and how do you make that overarching a
series as well? So there's two things I think about as I'm writing.
I think about that hero's journey in the context of one singular story and then
over what I hope will be a longterm series. So that's what I'm,
what I'm thinking about as I write these things. And then true believers,
the continuation of that story. But it's a,
I was inspired by somebody I met in Iraq in 2006 and I thought,
what have I made this interaction and what I,
when I heard through the grapevine later,
what if I made this a lot more interesting and fictionalized it?
And so that's where the,
the second one picks up and it's really a story of redemption and taking the,
was still taking the emotions and the feelings behind certain things that
happened down range. Uh,
but also now exploring what that transition was like because the hero you're in
the story, James Reece has to go through a transformative journey. And uh,
the second one's all about redemption
and when is, when does book two wins? True believer come out July 30th,
July 30th, that comes out. Internal list is out right now
is out. Yeah.
The second one should have come out April 2nd but the Department of Defense took
seven months to do a 30 day review.
A sort of make sure I was honoring my former security clearances by submitting
it to the deployment.
You just leave the stuff that they tell you to take out or the stuff that they
tell you to react. You just, you just black it out, black it out.
I didn't know if I ride around it and I still kind of funny as you did that and
true in the terminal list to you when you send it to me, I,
you gave me a heads up, he said, Hey I just blacked things out. And you know,
obviously my books had been, well not my kids' books,
but my other books had been through the Pentagon review and they tell you that
could remove certain things and we would remove it and change it.
So it's acceptable to them.
But you just blacked it out straight out of blacked out.
Yeah cause I was worried like what if I write around this and then I publish it
and then come back and say, well you didn't quite why right around that enough.
Did you do that just to be cool? Kind of.
And it also has little authenticity helps with the marketing. And it's like,
I mean I was, I was looking through it and I'm looking at like what is,
and I can, I can figure out a lot of them. I go, oh they, they,
they didn't want them to say that. Oh, they didn't want him to say that.
So it's pretty cool. But you can still,
I mean obviously you can still understand all the context around it.
You just don't know a certain like specific term or a certain specific location
or a certain specific name. But yeah, that's pretty, that's pretty cool.
Pretty cool that you left it in there and the books are available everywhere.
Everywhere, everywhere. You're audio people love the audio.
Ray Porter does the audio. He's an awesome dude.
He's up for audio book of the year this year.
So we were in New York and it's up there.
Well I texted you cause you're bucketing, you know you're in your,
in your s your category. So I was texting you,
I took a picture of the screen and everything. It was cool seeing it up there.
That's a Stephen King. I was like Dang, it's pretty cool. That was pretty cool.
Uh, you to find you, um,
you got your website, which is official Jack car.com.
That's it. Because you didn't buy the URL Jack Carr early thing,
an insurance guy has it in some guys holding it for hostage and your damn,
we're going to get it out. Well maybe you will never say never. So that's a,
yeah, that's a,
and that's one that people want to geek out a little more on the weapons,
the knives, that sorta thing. Um,
the website goes deep dives into a lot more of that stuff in the books cause you
get your nerd on. Yeah. You get your weapons nerd on, you're like,
you bring the librarian of your mom to the,
to the Damn Jack car weapons scene. That's it.
That's it. So it's on there. And, and uh, then on the socials,
which I am very new to, I'm about a year and half into this now it's a Jack car,
USA beyond the socials and there is a Facebook, but uh,
three was just too much like,
so somebody else just copies and paste things further into their,
but a on Instagram and Twitter,
Jaguar USA and there's the ones that I interact with the interacting in the
game. That's it. I'm in on those, but three years just to daunting,
just kind of, nope, nope. Prioritize all three.
The next level. I'm crazy like that.
That's how it's super motivated down on three social media platforms kill me
now. What, you know, usually I have a,
every now and again I have a hard time going to sleep in front of my mind's
racing. I'm thinking about all these things, thinking about storyline,
solving problems on the written page here aggressively like I used to do on the
battlefield. Um,
but usually I don't have a problem staying asleep once I get there this morning
up 3:07 AM and I'm like Dang. And I took a picture of it for you cause I'm like,
should you post it, you know, no do day to day. So I didn't, you know,
think that way. So I uh, I kept my d day post on point,
but I will, I will post it. DJ. Awesome. Yeah.
So I think that's a good place to wrap it. You know,
Echo Jack was just talking about fitness. He's talking about being prepared,
opened up, talking about being a true believer. That knows the cause. Yeah.
What do you know about, you know, sort of that cause being on the path,
believing in it, truly fully.
Do want to comment on how you blacked out the classified
parts of your book? Kind of like in the movies, right. When they want to,
you know, they show movies on HBO or in the Cinema, whatever. It's all good.
They put it on USA or one of these, you know, networks, they got to edit it.
Right. Edited for television. So there's three ways they do it in the movies.
They either just take out the whole scene,
which is like what they do with books. Right. Sometimes like I guess they could,
yeah. Usually change it. Yes. We'll do that. Movies too. In the movie version,
they have a dubbed voiceover for the swearing. Right.
And every once in a while you have a movie with an actual different scene.
Like if you watch trading places or something on you,
they have actual different scenes like that they redid. Sure.
Then the third is the blackout version and what you did,
which they just blanket out. So if they're swearing, he'll be like, what?
The and the mouth will show it, but they just won't have the audio. Right.
To me that's the best way to do it because it keeps you in the story.
You're like, okay he swore right there. I get it.
You can't swear on t on this network or whatever.
But in my opinion this, the blackout, the physical, like I just saw it in there.
It's physically blacked out. Anti highlighted, low lighted. Yep. Few of them.
It gives it the mystique. Yeah.
Of like there's something hidden under here that's classified that you can't
know about. So classified you can't know about. You can't even know about it.
Yeah. Even even that it's fiction, which is even a level up like half level up.
Even from
there redacting fiction that me
[inaudible] when he said like secret,
cause you and I both know what gets redacted. Ridiculous. It's not really,
not that I don't want to build it up too much.
So when we talk about [inaudible] we'll edit this out.
It's so top my plans for the first one I didn't, I didn't appeal.
So you got a year to appeal these things. And uh,
I didn't do it in the first one because I didn't have any enough money. Um,
so second one though, they just got a lot more in this second one.
And I'm appealing this one. So,
and what you do for the appeal is you find the information on government
websites. You can't just go to Wikipedia or whatever else,
but on actual government websites, in congressional testimony,
I'm out there via the government. Um,
so we're appealing this one and almost everything in there except for one little
phrase. Um, we found it on government website, so,
so we're appealing so that if the paperback comes out in this,
now you can see what the government didn't want you to see. But it's,
I don't want to build it up too much because it's really,
it's not as cool as it sounds, smells.
But one thing that they took out was so surprising as I made up.
So I made up a location because I been there. Yeah.
Before I came into the one in the military.
So I used it as location in the novel because it made sense where it started.
Second one is kind of starts in Africa and then it goes up here and you know,
it goes into whatever. But I'm like, God,
that'd be a good place for Kinda the cave. You gotta go there and change,
got to transform. And uh, so I just made it up cause I'd been there.
I can describe the rocks, I could describe the mountains,
I can describe the architecture. So I put it in there.
They blacked it all out and it's, I totally made up. They blacked it all out,
but they left in by accident, the, um, uh,
the capital of that country. So I blacked it out for them, knowing the intent,
knowing their intent. I took it out for them, but they missed that.
They took out the type of architecture they took out the mountains,
they took out any reference to the country, which is so strange.
But they left in by accident, the capital [inaudible] right. Yeah, exactly.
What else was up in that cave? You know,
exactly to this stranger than fiction. But that's good.
That's another selling point in a way. When you can say this,
like I'm revealing in this book what the government didn't want you to see.
Yeah, actually. Yep, exactly. So the paper bag. Yup. Yeah.
We'll see how it goes. Cool man. Well, one day, what did you revisit?
You did through it. What are you doing these harder to take heavies right now.
I know, I know. So I dabbled through the years. Um, but uh,
essentially what I did up until 95.
That's really my base and I got up like obviously I shoot a lot and obviously so
shoot all the time, stay in shape, that sort of thing. But uh,
the Jujitsu is wherever I am right now.
That is where my march old ground fighting skills are going to remain. Um,
we are, wait, why are you committing to that? Right?
The spine surgery to uh,
to just time wise and knowing where my focus needs to be right now.
What do you think, what do you think is worse for your spine?
Clean and jerks or grappling. Clean and jerks.
I'm going to have to agree like I'm not, I love cleaners. I don't,
I don't actually think cleaner drugs are bad for your spine.
I think they're good for your spine. But grappling, that's the,
this is the delve into how you get your information for your little books,
right? Oh yeah. You sent me a text or whatever, like two years ago. Hey,
if a guy was in Virginia wanting to train with like the best on the east coast,
where would he go and train you help you send me that text.
I'm like send them to hens. Oh, grace shared it. He got right back to me.
I appreciate it. Went right in the book.
That's these guys used research you've ever done. I was great. Jocko. Perfect.
And it made it right in the book and then I moved on. Right.
I feel bad when people text me and I don't text them back like right away.
Oh really? You must feel real bad with me then do the whole right away.
Real form.
But sometimes it just doesn't get a lot of texts and like you got to sit there
and you know,
but I try and text people back eventually or he might need to hit me with a
little follow mud or you'll follow up. Yeah man. Well, hey,
um,
well doing Jujitsu and peeking at 95 staying there is better than not picking
you. Just doing that. People at all.
The kids were in it right away and daughter and it, uh,
from maybe age four. Oh, just saying the game right now.
[inaudible] and so now that we're in what we need to talk. Yeah.
So she's a into snowboarding now and tennis, so she turned 13.
That's cool. Everything but I think age 11 or maybe 2011,
I think you might've stopped. Uh, she kind of, yeah, it's tough. That was tough.
The game. Is there a Jujitsu in park city?
I know there's full on Jujitsu in Utah. You got Pedro Sauer up there.
You got all kinds of good. Did you two people up in Salt Lake City? Yeah,
for sure. Yep. No, we sure do. And there's one, I think Pedro Sauer has,
I think a and a little offsite in park city neighborhood lead. So, uh,
of course we checked it out before the move. Uh, they moved San,
so I haven't followed where they moved to, but I think there's one still there.
Um, but cause it was important to me because at the time we moved,
my daughter was still in it and our little guy was in it. Uh,
our eight year old who's now at year old. Um,
so it was important to me that there was Jujitsu where we were moving and uh,
but now that we moved out, we get there and it's gone.
It's just like an empty space. So I think it's still there somewhere.
But the kids, you know, they're doing their, their things.
Unfortunately the scheme, there's a lot to do, a lot to do up there. But uh,
we know I dabbled over the,
over the years we're still doing it while I was in a knob. So,
or an XL is way before I got out, um, in Coronado cause it was right there.
I'd go at lunch and roll with some guys, some research where we can get you,
get you and your family back in the game up and up in park city. Cause I,
I personally feel like guilty to have your family not training to have you not
training and me doing a little bit that squared away.
I know you're taking some extreme ownership, right. Their car,
you're taking some extreme ownership of that.
Reese needs to be getting in the game and the stories to be fictionalized. Yeah.
James Reese is on it. He's training his digits too. But you got to get,
you know, you talk about transferring those emotions, right? Real world.
I remember. How,
do you remember what it feels like to get just thrown around the mat?
The floor wiped, you know? Yeah. I was worried.
That's why I didn't tell you I was coming in last night.
I noticed I didn't get that. I didn't,
I was worried that I'd be up at three something getting just destroyed on the
mat. He just, yeah, he is out. So, you know, either way,
if that need is rapidly approaching yet and it's been rapidly hot for a long
status, all good. And we're gonna look forward to that.
So back to you just do, when you get back in,
did you see you're gonna need a gate or if you're getting in to just do for the
first time, you're gonna need a g d g Nogi do both.
That's the best 100% of the way. If you're at Park City, Utah,
if you get no fighting park city, Utah,
the other person is almost guaranteed to be wearing a geek type out right now.
Let's do home straight up wearing a jacket. Good point. You started weight,
always caught up wearing a north face Parka, right?
Just Patagonia. Boom.
It's very possible that going to pell on a Patagonia jacket. Yeah.
Let's get some of that sleep. What's the Patagonia jacket? It's just the jacket.
It's like a Parka. This is another,
I had explained to me what a Parker was on one podcast. Wow. He's from Hawaii.
Wow. I don't know. I never heard of that, but nonetheless. Sounds Nice.
Sounds good. Uh, similar to a g top. Good. All right. We're going to do g,
what kind of gear we're going to get? Do you know?
I know origin origin only 100%. There's only
one that's one in the world. Why would you not get the best one in the world?
There's no reason percent get the best one in the world.
Cause the best one costs five times more than the not best one. No.
Or is it all kids the same? Nope. Same. Same cost. While you can choose,
you can grab the, the big deadlocks. A, what do you call,
what's the word you always do? Use. Not always, but luxurious.
Luxurious. Last. You can grab down if you want. Good. Good. Up to you.
Origin keys and various, uh,
what do you call like options of keys all made in America though, by the way.
Speaking of made in America, you get other clothes made in America,
namely t-shirts. Yeah, sure. But also sweatshirts. Yeah.
And also newest latest jeans,
which I have some on the way, by the way, I'll finally be little. We teamed up,
we teamed up. We're going to blank.
We're in a secondary group me and be little Brian Little field. Um,
and you know, we're, we're tight, we're in the game, whatever. Right?
But we're always last to get the cool new stuff. Jocko always first,
Pete always first, right? US always, we're not even second,
we're not even third. We're last every time.
And then the last we banded together and now I have a pair of origin jeans made
in America. American denim jeans on the way to me.
So please happy to announce Allen to everyone. Also rash guards,
of course, other Jujitsu stuff as well.
Also supplements the most important kinds of supplements.
Boom joints keep you in the game. Protein keep you in the game.
The white tea is Jocko white tea. A supplement? Yes. Yeah,
because it has to be a supplement because what else would give you an 8,000
pounds? I look at your app. You're absolutely right. Nothing.
And it's certified organic. So the whole water thing? Nope.
How'd you like your first Jocko white tea.
I couldn't do the podcast without having one sales people. Some people don't.
It's not sweet, you know, there's no sugar in there. Nope. It's just tea.
It's great, but it tastes,
but it has the pomegranate little fruitiness to it that keeps you wanting more.
I'm a big fan. Big Fan of have to, you know,
you should get some of those deadlift and then go right. Cause whenever I,
whenever I write, that's guaranteed. Right. That's guaranteed.
Like at least 300 words come and are coming at you live, oozy, smooth,
run it off your finger until I get into the computer,
my marching orders also discipline by the way, speaking of writing.
Oh that's a good one.
I found and I don't write as much is you?
You might not have known that, but you know,
but I make these videos every once in a while if you're on the disciplines or
even that kind of comes a lot easier when you're doing.
And so stay up everyone. We lie to ourselves. Yeah,
that is a good one. That is a good one. Yeah.
Accurate representation of yourself can't grow otherwise. It's true.
It's absolutely true. But yeah, discipline, that's a good on and discipline go.
If you don't want to, don't mix it up and do all that stuff.
If you're on the go essentially. Right. That's,
that's where it goes in the last makes sense. And then you just go,
you get milk, which is additional protein. Yeah.
For your life because we all know we're eating steak. Yes. Reading chicken.
Some people are eating Sushi. Yes sir. We are a lot of Sushi.
That all gives you protein, which is good.
Sometimes you need a little bit more or sometimes you just want it.
So dessert is there straight up. Have you tried the,
I have not yet. So looking forward to it though. Just just, it's ridiculous.
You ever had a Nestle strawberry quick? Yes. It's been a long time.
Did you like it? I always, yes. I like the chocolate one. I think that okay.
You like to try. Some people are like that. I've never tried them both.
But I go back to the chocolate,
the strawberry slayer mock tastes absolutely delicious.
And then we have where your kid milk. So for your kids. Yeah,
totally good to go. I keep meaning to get that too. Cause our kids, man,
they do not anyway. Yeah cause your kids want to eat cake.
They want to drink Nestle's quick cause it's tasty still.
I don't have to do that. Nope. They can get protein.
No sugar. You know what's up and it tastes delicious. All right, cool. Cool.
So there's that where your kid mall Malke and then if you want like this shirt
that echo's wearing this good shirt. The second one go to our store.
Collectively. Everyone's, this isn't a no cause you keep calling it my store.
It's not my store. It has your name in it. Yeah. No, but everybody goes there.
It's not just me in the store by myself. You are the store is for everyone.
Right. It's true. It's not your store. It's not my story.
It's our store collectively as a group. The Jack Carr Story. Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah. So that
is@jockostore.com if you want to represent on this path, right?
Discipline equals freedom. Shit. Good mentality, right.
Looking for the good in the bad quote unquote bad again, it, you know,
whatever you want to reference your home. That's where you get your stuff.
Speaking of which you are talking Jocko white tea,
I don't know if you saw this Tam, Tom Clancy, a fan that you are.
Did you see that in the latest Tom Clancy novel, the uh,
Jack Ryan. You know what he drinks? Oh, I saw this. Yeah.
I didn't read it but I saw it. Somebody posted a picture and put it out there,
Jocko. Yep. Jack Ryan's in the game.
We're wondering what James Reese is going to be drinking in book three.
You'd have to stand by [inaudible] find out
[inaudible] it's definitely,
we know easier to be wearing like the warrior kid in three book. You know what?
[inaudible] being ward origin. Nice. Yeah. Boom. There you go. So yeah,
everybody's representing. So yeah, you want to represent,
even if you're already represent, you want to represent,
represent more chocolate store at com. Boom. Hoodies, tee shirts, rash guards,
hats, everything. Patches, everything.
Subscribe to this podcast so you can hear Jack Carr and others talking about
their experiences and then leave reviews so that I can laugh at your funny
reviews or be like, do you ever had nod to your computer?
Like you're looking at your computer, you read,
you read a solid review and you just give that review a little, a little late,
not little and all that. Not for that thing.
Like somebody wrote a damn good review the other day and I read it. I was like,
you know, gave him one of those physical,
physical movement at my computer until 11 o'clock at night. What am I doing?
Reading reviews, trying to go to sleep.
You're talking about how you have no problem going to sleep? Sometimes I do. No,
I was, I have some trouble going to sleep. Well,
I have trouble going to sleep that way. It's at a, it's trouble waking up.
Oh yeah. Oh, you have trouble waking up. Yeah, I mean I'd rather sleep in,
but I do get up. Well that 5:00 AM it comes quick. Yeah.
And finally I let him down at 3:00 AM like he would finally the guys at five 30
knock it out home at seven help with the kids then start writing shit. No,
that solid right there. That's fine.
We'll get some stuff for your crew up there. Get them in the game. Awesome.
Absolutely. They have a nod. That's like level one.
I'm like re like what do you call? There's base level respect, right?
There's extra respect and then there's the ceiling above the ceiling.
There's level one. Respect when physical head nods for computer. Yeah.
Level two claps. Claps for you. Seems like you clap for the,
for the performer. That's different bro. No,
I would never in a million years clap. I'm like am I? No cause that's fine.
[inaudible] level two but someone's going to come up with like a review or
something and it'll warn a clap. That's my contention.
We had a good one that I know yesterday. [inaudible] your computer.
Somebody wrote a Jack Carr has a graduate degree in the art of war.
Oh liked it? Positive Ed.
Positive head check.
Look someone else at one rock up that someone else wrote one about if John Wick
the punisher and somebody else had a child would be James Reese. I'm like, yeah,
it's going check this out 100%. Yeah, man. So yeah,
subscribe, man. If you're into it and you want to write a review,
you do it also, don't forget about where your kid podcasts, which is not dead.
No, it's, it's, it's been, um, resurrected. Well it's not, it was never danced.
Resurrected. No. Yeah, it is alive and well, however,
there hasn't been a lot of new additions lately, but they're coming,
they're coming. Boom. There you go. So I was mentally going through
possibilities for the next story from Uncle Jake. Right.
So yeah. So the pendulum was just a way,
pendulums away from warrior kid podcast. Yeah.
Actually now that book eight is almost wrapped. That's what,
that's what the,
that's what the prioritize and execute is on just going gonna say you beat me to
the waiting to get in there with parents. Yeah, exactly. Yep.
So that's where it could broadcast. And if you want to support a warrior kid,
then you can get some Jocko soap, Yemen,
warrior kid soap from Irish oaks,
ranch.com young Aiden or your kid making so,
and don't forget about youtube channel.
Don't forget to like subscribe and Click. What do they say?
What do they say? I think they think like subscribing. No, wait something,
some other thing that you're supposed to do. Yes. If you're that. Okay.
So anyways, youtube channel. Yeah, that's it. Yeah,
so if you want to do those things, whatever,
and that's where you can get echoes, echos,
videos that he spends all allegedly so much time making balloons and they come
out once every, every four years like the Olympics,
the Winter Olympics in Park city. It's every four years.
A good video is going to come out. Whatever. Check her likes, some soap, boom.
Deal every posted through. Boom. There you go.
See, thanks. Thanks for that by the way. All right. Psychological warfare.
Go ahead. No, I'm giving it to you. I put your name there.
Psychological warfare. If you don't know what that is, this is what it is.
It's an album with tracks Jocko track. Anyway, he on those tracks,
he tells you how to get through moments of weakness,
like if you're about to eat the wrong thing because for the short term,
because there's short game, long game, listen to this. 100% works by the way.
So if you're like, okay, I'm going to can life, this is what I learned.
It's one of the biggest things. People ask me this all the time.
I would say literally anyone who has questions quote unquote for me,
this is one of the questions they'll ask.
What's the biggest thing you learned from Jocko? I'll tell you right now,
here it is. If you look at things short term versus long term,
small picture, big picture, and then there's like another one, whatever.
But either way it's all the same thing short term.
So in psychological warfare you're going short game.
If you're going to start playing the short game for that moment, this will this,
you're gonna lose the short game in the moment. As you were just saying,
if you're going to, if you're going to take a short term,
short term is going to have immediate gratification, but it's a long term down.
Yes, exactly right. And most of the time, not all the time,
but most of the times short term, if you play short, short game,
you lose the long game. With that play, it's like you take a short term,
step forward and take a long step back. It's one of those deals.
Usually you can break things down into that. So this is what this does.
I'm getting that because I need to listen to that while I'm at whole foods and
I'm getting up there ready to get to that register and they have those peanut
butter cups. Oh, all natural. All natural animal
[inaudible]. Exactly. All that. Better than that orange
[inaudible] weird is all natural. Same thing.
What are we doing over here? Just gotta listen to that as I'm checking out.
Right.
That's perfect actually because actually it's good because you can actually have
it in the queue, you know? Because a lot of times,
like you're just in the pantry wherever you are and you're like, boom,
I'm looking for the good stuff. Whatever. Boom. I see the, the,
the Oreos brought my, you can't just go, Oh let me queue it up.
Sometimes it gets hard as what I'm saying Bro. My son, okay, can drive now.
Right. Which means he can go to the store,
which means he can shop for food. Right? We're talking 16 year old boy.
What does he get at the store? [inaudible] worth talking to y'all natural.
Oh he just gets crazy. So he'll be like, I'm hungry.
Go into the store, comes home, what does he come home with?
Half Gallon of whatever ice cream makes sense. Cause you know,
the supermarkets they formulate or they design the store and the product course
a certain way. So like boom, boom.
That's why they put the Reese's peanut butter right at the,
at the checkout they call them impulse buys. Right?
And that goes for everything. Little magazines and balloons and all that.
You know what that is? That's their psychological warfare. That's what it is.
Their psychological warfare.
And then you've got to combat that with psychological warfare.
Chocolate's psychological flanking me. Definitely can. Absolutely.
Cause I can avoid the aisle and avoid the snack aisle.
You're not even going down there,
but you got to checkout and that's why they got them. That's your weakness Bro.
They're so good.
But that's what your boy is essentially falling for when he goes in. He's like,
Hey, I'm going to go here near you so that's where you're wrong.
He's not going up there. [inaudible]
he's leaving the house and he's thinking the briars. Okay.
That's where these ads do. Yes. He's, he goes and gets cakes like dude,
the plan is, you know,
honestly the ice cream thing has really taken a down hit at my house cause mark.
Right. Cause everyone just kind of on the milk tray that makes like,
but my son will get straight up chocolate chip cookies.
Just that's what he did last night. That's why this is fresh on my mind.
Comes home,
nine o'clock goes to the store at eight 40 like we already ate dinner.
Okay. Where are you going?
I'm just going to go to the store and he's only thinking about one thing.
He's not thinking about lettuce, thinking about apples.
He's thinking chocolate chip cookies. Yes.
Coming back with the big chunks in them like the premium and then this little
kid brings him into my house. You know what I mean?
It's a good way to get shanked actually. Psychological warfare,
big time shit. Like probably get to that home. All the tape.
If you want to go visual, visual, psychological warfare for yourself.
Check out flip side, canvas.com my brother Dakota Meyer,
who's awesome, veteran marine,
incredible guy.
Started this company making art to hang on your wall and you can,
it says cool stuff on it. Like good,
like discipline equals freedom and he's got a whole array of doing stuff.
So check that out. Flip side, campus.com and if you want him to make something,
tweet him. Yeah, tweet. Tweet the Dakota Meyer. Say, put this on a canvas.
You'll figure it out. You'll make it happen. So true. Also on it.
Will you go to [inaudible] dot com slash Jocko this is where you can get your
kettlebells. You're getting kettlebells, you know on it, right? Yeah. We've seen
those kiddos there before. Do you guys work out the home gym?
Where are you guys working out now? Now we go down. It's really cool.
They have a full on my crossfit type set up at the gym and there's an indoor
track. Um, it's, it's amazing pool right there, but it's a,
it's full on like crossfit asks out thing and you can go get it. Yup.
And they leave you alone. Yup. Two bowl the other day. And guess what?
No chalk was allowed. Really notices gym section
when you, you to talk about it. Was it a hotel? Jamerson it was a,
but it was really a proper gym. Hey, it was a gym that had bumper plates.
It was a gym that had six squat racks,
no power squat, no six squat racks. I'm in this gym, no chalk.
If they have bumpers, eight kettlebells, no chalk. They had pull bars,
no chocolates. That's a real problem. I can see like, you know, hey,
if you're into 24 hour fitness and you're, you got the, the,
the universal machines or whatever that echo's out there to JMU,
that's yacking anyway, nothing gets universal by the way. But you know,
let's keep it real anyway on it. Kettlebells, whatever.
Yes. So that's where I get my kettlebells.
Kettlebell routine in general is good, do kettle,
but a lot of what mo did as far as your spine and whatever,
and I was going to ask you earlier,
but what does that like keep you from doing mainly? Well,
I wake up but it hurts all the time. But uh,
every time I turned my head and I realize just how lucky I am that after 20
years and all those things, like that's all I have to deal with. So it's a,
it's mobility, it hurts whatever surgery. But a c six c seven spine,
they went to know, not know the military wanted to fuse me, but luckily I had,
I've got a second opinion and they went in and shaved off of a bone spur in
there that was crushing a nerve that was making my left arm.
Was it like a foraminotomy? I don't think they use that term. That's what I got.
But a unethical back. Yep. C 67 got to go back in there. But uh,
every time it hurts, I'm just like, you know, there's guys out there for PTSD,
TBI, missing arms and legs just destroyed. And a, this is all I have. Yup.
And a good, Yup. Seriously. Yep. Absolutely.
Um, some of them would keep me from doing anything. It just reminds me,
so I use it as a, here's a reminder that I'm very, very lucky, very fortunate.
So you can, you can push it but just not get nuts and yup. I still got,
you know,
I keep trying to keep up and if anything I'm trying to take it easy on goes out
the window. I just said that's just like, let's just roll.
It's just roll at 20% I remember those. Yeah, exactly. Not happening,
so I remember well, yeah. Good. Then kettlebells, right? Right. Yup.
My point was you do kettle bells. You get that functional strength back,
whatever, boom. Non P. I mean you're backed up prohibiting, boom,
you're into kettlebells. Yup. Absolutely.
Almost every day when we're working out with the whole, with the crew.
Well yeah, so yeah. All my kettlebells,
kettlebells and then we've got some dogs. If you want books, if you like books,
first of all, the terminal list and true believer by Jack Carr,
check those out. Get into the,
I believe you just said the psychological mind field
of this dude who's on the serious warpath already dead get so way the warrior
kid three is out.
It's live and you can get that on amazon.com where there's a will is the
subtitle of that book. Find out what happens to young mark,
how Uncle Jake helps him out way the where your kid one and then way the warrior
could do Mark's mission. Those are also available. Mikey and the dragons.
You can get that one for any kid between the ages of zero and 150 and they're
going to get something out of it. The discipline equals freedom field manual.
Get that. That's what you want to get your kid that just graduated.
That's what you want to get your employee.
That seems to be sliding off the track.
That's what you want to get your friend that is letting themselves go down the
slippery slope. Yes. Taking the short term gratification on stuff. No,
you get them. The discipline equals freedom field manual.
The audio version of that is on iTunes, Amazon music.
It's a MP three format.
Then there's extreme ownership and the dichotomy leadership where you can take
these lessons from combat. Me and my brother Leif Babin wrote that book,
those books and how you can apply those lessons to your business,
to your life.
We've got Ashkelon Front leadership consultancy and what we do is solve problems
through leadership. We also have ef online where you can,
you can continue to train leadership because you never master it.
You never met. You never even really get good at it. It's,
you always have to be working at it. So we have online work at it,
work at it every day. Do what happens if you stop working out.
Do you stay in shape? Echo, chas, negative.
What happens if you stop trying to become a good leader? Same. Same thing.
You go backwards. Get rusty beyond rusty.
We're talking catastrophic. Just lose it. Yeah, we're talking.
You turn into a leadership slob. Yes. You don't want no, you want to be sharp.
You want to be in tune. Yeah.
I experienced this because I get to see it all the time with the companies we
work with. Like I see someone that's like early in the game and they're sharp,
they're there,
their leadership is sharp and then all of a sudden they slack off for awhile and
they have a leadership problem and they handle it wrong.
Just like they couldn't Mack,
they couldn't do 42 pull ups like they could before.
Now they're doing 30 to why they haven't been trained.
Got To keep your leadership brain sharp. You ever done 42 pull ups now?
Like my mind was 30 something was my, was my best.
I think it's still 30 something in high school when I was at very,
very light and there are two sets of 20 I still remember that was my thing came
on that bike seeps. That's it. That's what's interesting.
And that was getting ready for buds essentially.
That was high school but still I still had a little time.
But you're still at a time.
I was still training and what I was going to say is like for me getting ready
for buds was I was like Bro, I did.
I did three sets of pull ups today cause we didn't know how had to do 250 pull
ups per workout. Right. 350 pull ups work out. I didn't think of that.
It didn't even make sense to me. Right.
It was 19 it was 1989 1990 wow.
[inaudible] there was no way to access this information. No.
So you're never going to be doing the same number of pull ups as your class
number. Yeah. Yeah. How, how many? That's what we're going to do. Yeah.
By the way, we're doing it tomorrow too after lunch. So get some of that.
So that's the same thing. Physical, mental,
get your leadership mindset sharp, keep it sharp.
Eff Online. If you want to come to the muster,
you better sign up now cause they're all sold out there.
They all sell out very quickly. Chicago sold out.
Denver's heading that way that September 19th and 20th and then Sydney,
Australia.
Looking forward to that coming down and meeting y'all people in Australia.
Again if you want to come to that extreme ownership.com and then EIF, Overwatch.
If you are looking for someone in your company that knows how to lead,
then check out f overwatch.com where we've got special operators and we got
combat aviation leaders that are transitioning into the civilian sector and can
help you and your team using the principles of combat leadership that we read
about in extreme ownership and the academy leadership.
So if overwatch.com and if you want to hear more from us,
if 500 hours of listening isn't enough than we are on the interwebs.
Twitter, Instagram and Facebook
echos. Echo Charles,
I'm at Jockowillink and Jack is at Jack Carr.
USA. Echo. Anything else? Nothing else. Thank you. Jet Car.
Thank you guys so much for having me on. It's a pleasure to be here.
I feel very fortunate that uh, getting out,
we were able to kind of make the life we want on the outside. Um,
can defy a few odds along the way and that's all because, because my life, um,
the 19 coming up on 19 years, I'll stay on this month and uh, and uh, yeah,
so because of her strength raising those kids while I was away,
now I can tell that a little bit. Hopefully not mess it up, um,
got to getting into her routine. But uh, yeah, she's amazing.
Super Strong love with all my heart. My next, uh,
this next mission in life really is all about her and them. That's awesome.
Well,
thanks once again for coming on and obviously thanks for your service to America
as the healers. You had an awesome,
awesome run and you were deployed over and over and over again.
And even though we joke about, you know,
what a good time it is and we did have a good time. I know you had a good time,
but at the same time, you know you're making sacrifices,
your family's home alone and that's huge. So thanks to you,
thanks to your family, thanks to your wife for,
for having the strength to deal with that and appreciate you and,
and it's awesome to see what you're doing right now. Thanks brother.
Appreciate it. To anyone else that's listening that is serving right now,
where has served thanks to you for keeping us a free and to police and to law
enforcement and firefighters and paramedics and e mts and dispatchers and
correctional officers and border patrol and secret service and all the first
responders that are out there 24 hours a day and they're training and they're
preparing and they're on call so that we can be safe here at home.
Thanks to all of you for that service and for that sacrifice.
Okay.
Into everyone else that is listening.
Remember that?
Okay?
There's always somebody out there with their sights on you.
It may be it's a competitor in business. Maybe it's an enemy and the surgeon,
maybe it's some criminal Fogg.
Maybe it's someone that's just looking to do harm to you or your family,
or maybe,
okay,
maybe that's someone who's you.
Yeah.
It may be you're your own worst enemy.
Sliding into the depths of complacency,
allowing yourself to wander down the easy path.
Say No to that.
Okay?
Remember why you're here. Remember what you want to do.
Remember your cause. Be a true believer,
okay?
And then live that belief
by getting up every day. Then getting after it,
and until next time,
this is Jack Carr and deco and Jocko out.